Drück mal. Also wir fangen hier gerade an. Jetzt ist an, ja.
Herzlich willkommen bei Fritz, hier ist der Blue Moon, das Chaosradio.
Gehen wir am ersten Montag neuerdings, am ersten Montag im Monat, am letzten Montag im Monat, am letzten ersten Tag in der Woche im Monat.
Andi?
Würdest du mir jetzt bitte da raushelfen? Okay, also Chaosradio 53. Wir stellen uns vielleicht wieder kurz vor, aber erst mal stellen wir das Thema vor. In Chaosradio 53 heute geht es über die Freiheit der Bits. Das klingt ganz einfach, ist aber mitunter ganz kompliziert. Weil wenn wir im Internet da so freien Fluss der Informationen haben und die Datenleitungen rauf und runter munter irgendwelche Dinge hin und her transferieren, dann halten das Juristen mitunter, was wir da tun, für Diebstahl. Die sagen, das sind ja Produkte, bestimmte Anordnungen von Bits, und was wir da tun, ist, geistiges Eigentum zu schauen. Und überhaupt, wenn sich Bits vermehren, ist das für die kein Sex, sondern eben ein Verstoß gegen das Urheberrechtsgesetz. Und jetzt stellt sich die Frage entweder wir schaffen die Juristen die Urheberrechtsgesetze, die Patentgesetze, das Copyright, und das geistige Eigentumsrecht für sich ab, oder aber die Jungs werden uns das Internet zumachen. Und da wir nun allerdings auch Verständnis dafür haben, dass Künstler sich finanzieren wollen, wollen wir auch darüber heute reden. Wir sagen, wir haben hier so vier Positionen mindestens im Raum, ne fünf, also wie üblich fünf Teilnehmer. Und das heißt wir haben ungefähr 23 verschiedene Meinungen zu diesem Thema. Und ich werde heute hier die Radikalposition vertreten. Und vielleicht kann man der nächste weiter machen. Tim, was willst du heute?
Was ich heute will?
Ja, was ist deine Position zu diesem Thema?
Meine Position ist generell, dass wir den Jingle ausspielen lassen sollten am Anfang.
Ach echt?
Gut, ich bin dagegen.
Wir können jetzt leider kein Plenum machen.
Wir dürfen den Radikal nicht einfach den Boden überlassen.
Ja, das war also Tims Meinung. Fragen wir mal, wow, was ist deine Meinung?
Das kann ich nicht in einem Satz zusammenfassen.
Und du, Frank, hast du auch eine Meinung?
Ich finde, dass das eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht ist, wie das Moment aussieht, was sich die Juristen da überlegt haben. Und dass es eben zeigen muss, wie das in der Zukunft ausgelegt wird. Ich denke, dass sich die Juristen da auch ein bisschen entspannen sollten. Vor allem auch die Plattenfirmen und so Leute wie Smudo. Ich denke, dass das alles nicht so dramatisch ist. Und dass wir hier in Deutschland eigentlich von einer gesetzlichen Regelung her schon ganz gut dastehen im Vergleich zu Amerika.
Du findest es also ganz gut, dass sie uns hier bald Filter installiert werden, ja? Dass dann die FP der Bundesverband der phonographischen Industrie kommt und den Internet-Service-Provider so Filter auferlegt.
Naja, das ist im Moment eigentlich gar nicht der Trend, wenn man die Diskussion nicht so oberlegt.
Das ist nicht der Trend, denn die ist doch auch gar keine Zeitung. Das haben die vor.
Die FP hat das vor, ja, das ist richtig. Aber die sind jetzt zum Glück nicht die Weltregierung.
Gut, was sagt denn der Moderator dazu? Ist der heute ganz moderat?
Ne, also ich bin sowieso für die Abschaffung von allem, also auch von Grundbilder. Aber wir müssen jetzt leider erstmal Captain Future hören.
Wir haben leider auch noch eine kleine Absage zu machen, heutige leider nicht anwesend, der liebe Ecke. Wir haben am letzten Dienstag in unserem chaotischen Plenum das Thema der Sendung ein bisschen vordiskutiert über Urheberrechte, über die Abschaffung geistigen Eigentums und ganzen Fragen und Ecke hat immer einen sehr, sehr sinnvollen Beitrag gemacht. Er sagte in rhythmischen Abständen mit monoton gleichnautenden Worten Sozialromantiker, schließlich sogar Kommunisten.
Andy, dann beschreib doch mal, was du für ein T-Shirt hast.
Deswegen habe ich mir unbedingt extra dieses rote 5-Zack-Sternhemd hier angezogen. Und Ecke hat aus verständlichen anderweitigen Gründen leider abgesagt. Aber wir widmen diese Sendung sicherlich Ecke und denken immer mit der Schere im Kopf an, die Gefahr zum Sozialromantiker zu werden.
Ja und wenn schon. Wenn wir über Urheberrecht reden, dann müssen wir auch mal über Grundbesitz reden. Das finde ich nämlich ähnlich absurd.
Ja, das ist auffällig okay. Deswegen, ich meine, im Netz haben wir ja, ich bin ja eine Zeit lang immer so als Sprecher des Vereins auch so auf Veranstaltungen unterwegs und immer wenn Juristen im Raum sind und ich das Wort Informationsfreiheit ausspreche, da steht drinnen unsere Satzung drin, das heißt, das ist einer der ersten Dinge, über die ich dann so bei der Selbstvorstellung üblicherweise referiere, wenn es um diesen Club geht, dann kommen auch manchmal Leute und sagen, aha, da will also einer die Eigentumsfrage diskutieren. Am Anfang dachte ich noch, die haben mich falsch verstanden, aber mittlerweile sage ich, jawohl, klar will ich die Eigentumsfrage diskutieren, zumindest wenn ihr anfängt, Informationen als Eigentum zu deklarieren und da euch drauf zu setzen und zu sagen, das darf aber keiner haben, der mir nicht Asche zahlt.
In Wirklichkeit liegt das Urheberrecht bei Gott.
Okay, die Frage ist, müssen wir jetzt...
Der redet aber nicht mit uns.
Nein, ich bin auch dagegen, weil das hieße, dass ich regelmäßig da irgendwie hingehen muss und Ablass kaufen muss oder irgendwie Richtung Mekka oder wo du auch immer sitzt, beten musst und ihm irgendwie huldigen musst und sagen musst, danke, dass du diesen ganzen Schass in hier erfunden hast.
Man nennt das einen Kirchensteuer an die...
Noch früher war es so, da gab es Windsteuer, weil der Wind das jemunische Kind ist und da haben dann die Windmühlenbesitzer Steuern an die Kirche gezahlt.
Da haben wir ja nochmal Glück gehabt.
Windmühlensteuer an die Kirche, alles klar. Das ist ja auch eine supergeile Idee.
Nachdem der Fernmeldewind, also jetzt für die Frequenzen 98, 5 Milliarden zu zahlen, ist die moderne Fortschreibung davon.
Ja, ich meine gut, aber das ist nicht ganz die moderne Fortschreibung davon, sondern das ist eigentlich die Privatisierung der Luft, was da gerade passiert ist. Und ich meine, nachdem irgendwie Wasser und was mich alles schon... Also Wasser wird ja auch an einigen Aktienmärkten schon richtig gehandelt. Also jegliche natürlichen Ressourcen sind eigentlich schon börsennotierte Angelegenheiten. Die Luft, das Wasser, was bleibt uns denn noch? Irgendwie das alles, was noch bleibt, sind die Gedanken. Bei Gedanken sagt man zwar, die sind frei, aber was sind Gedanken? Gedanken sind Anordnungen von Bits. Und auch die sollen natürlich Produkte sein.
Gedanken sind erst dann Werke, weil sie tatsächlich zu Papier gebracht worden.
Sind oder irgendwo anders hin gebracht werden, in einer sichtbaren oder hörbaren Form.
Also wir produzieren hier gerade Produkte, Werke, glücklicherweise.
Was gibt es denn jetzt, vielleicht kommen wir ja dann auch mal zum Überblick des Ist-Zustand. Also wir sind jetzt hier gerade gedankenabsondernd dabei, ein Werk zu schaffen.
Ich glaube wir klauen hier eigentlich nur aus dem Kollektiv.
Jetzt bleiben wir erstmal dabei. Wir produzieren jetzt gerade ein Werk, das heißt Chaosradio 53, ist voraussichtlich drei Stunden lang. Welche Rechte genießen wir denn jetzt an diesem Werk?
Naja, das Urheberrecht am Wort, das hier geschieht.
Wir kommen und das irgendwie als CD verkaufen und dafür irgendwie 50 Marken benötigen.
Ich fasse noch mal kurz zusammen, welche Gesetze gibt es konkret, die jetzt sozusagen diesen Vorgang in irgendeiner Form rechtlich begleiten?
Also in Deutschland haben wir da in erster Linie das Urheberrecht. Das ist so recht weit gefasst. Das gibt in der EU einen, naja, man hat sich jetzt da auf was geeinigt, was auch so Urheberrecht heißt, was im Wesentlichen auch das deutsche Recht, mit dem deutschen Recht irgendwie einklang steht.
Wurdest du das dann auch ablösen? Also ich meine, ist das dann ein als EU-übergreifendes nationales Recht ablösendes Gesetz geplant?
Es gibt ein paar Richtlinien. Es gibt da so einen Bericht der Kommission, da kann ich nachher noch ein bisschen was dazu erzählen vielleicht, wo also so ein paar Eckwerte festgelegt worden sind.
Die Waschbesagen?
Wo zum Beispiel geklärt ist, was ein Werk ist, was schutzfähig ist. Da geht es in erster Linie aber auch über Computerprogramme, Datenbankwerke, das heißt also, welch ein großer Streit, D-Info, CD, das heißt also, ist ein Telefonbuch irgendwie eine Datenbank, die mit erheblichem Aufwand erstellt wurde oder nicht so? Das ist irgendwie eine schwierige Frage.
Gibt es denn da eigentlich prinzipiell eine Unterscheidung zwischen Werken? Also was wir hier machen, ist von mir aus, wenn du es so nennen willst, ja ein Werk, aber das machen wir ja ganz bewusst für den öffentlichen Raum. Wir freuen uns darüber, wenn er das aufnimmt, wenn er das durchs Internet pustet, wenn sich das die Japaner und die Nordkoreaner und die Südkoreaner und die Afghanen und die Isanisten, die Eskimos genau anhören können und wir finden das sogar toll, wenn er darüber spricht, das verändert, da haben wir überhaupt kein Problem mit. Weil das machen wir ja nicht, um auf diesem Eigentumsrecht zu sitzen, sondern wir machen das, weil wir hier drei Stunden Spaß haben und weil es nebenbei noch ein bisschen uns die Klubraummiete finanziert.
Meldet ihr das denn eigentlich auch an die VG-Word-Verwertungsgesellschaft Wort? Nein, das ist dadurch, dass dieses Programm ja auch irgendwie in Kneipen und so was gehört werden kann.
Um Himmel zu heben.
Und diese Kneipiers, die müssen eben eine Urheberrechtsabgabe zahlen, also in so einem großen Topf und einmal im Jahr wird dieser große Topf über alle Leute, die im Radio was erzählt haben, ausgeschüttet. Das heißt, du füllst einen Zettel aus am Ende des Jahres, schickst ihn an die VG-Board und da steht drin, wir haben zwölf Mal drei Stunden gelabert. Und dafür kriegst du dann, ich weiß es nicht, pro Minute so und so viel Pfennige.
Also die Labersteuer.
Sozusagen.
Super.
Die haben jetzt allerdings irgendwie was da dran gedreht, dass es nicht mehr so viel Geld gibt. Also bis letztes Jahr gab es da absurde Summen für selbst irgendwie mal die Uhrzeit sagen.
Aha, wer ist dann im eigentlichen Sinne der Urheber? Ist das einfach derjenige, der spricht oder ist das dann die Radiostation als Ganzes?
Nein, Urheber kann nach dem deutschen Recht oder dem europäischen Recht immer nur eine natürliche Person sein. Also es kann zum Beispiel nicht sein, dass ein Computer per Zufallsgenerator irgendwas erzeugt und das dann urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Das heißt also es muss immer ein Urheber geben, was eine natürliche Person ist. Zum Beispiel kann eine Firma auch nicht Urheber sein. Das heißt, wenn du als Programmierer irgendwo angestellt bist und für diese Firma etwas programmierst, dann bist du nach wie vor der Urheber. Es gibt da aber eine Trennung zu den Nutzungsrechten. Die hat dann wahrscheinlich die Firma, weil du mit der Firma einen Arbeitsvertrag schließt, wo geregelt ist, wer die Nutzungsrechte hat. Und die hat dann die Firma. Das heißt, die Firma kann dann mit diesen Sachen machen, was sie will, aber sie ist eben nicht Urheber im Sinne des Gesetzes. Und dieses Urheberrecht ist zumindest in Deutschland, das ist der feine Unterschied zu Amerika oder ein feiner Unterschied zu Amerika. Dieses Urheberrecht ist nicht übertragbar. Das heißt, du hast dieses Werk geschaffen, du bist eben ein Mensch, eine Person und dir kann eben niemand absprechen, dass du das gemacht hast. Das ist einfach de facto so.
Ja, aber wozu denn diesen ganzen Scheiß? Also ich meine, wenn wir jetzt im Internet hier so munter mit den Bits flutschen und da das Problem haben, dass bestimmte Anordnung von Bits eben nach diesem komischen Urheberrechts-Dings dargesetzt, wie es auch immer heißt, eben Werke sind und als solchen das eben verboten ist, weil wir den Inhaber des Urheberrechts nicht gefragt haben, ob wir seine Bits uns jetzt gerade anhören dürfen oder ob wir die gerade kopieren dürfen oder ob wir mit denen gerade sonst was machen dürfen, dann ist es doch einfach eine Einschränkung unserer Freiheit, etwas zu tun. Und da diese Leute doch ohnehin das alles nur aus dem kollektiven Unterbewusstsein geschöpft haben und dann behauptet haben, es sei ihr's und sie hätten das erfunden, ist es doch total absurd.
Moment, sie haben auf jeden Fall nicht nur was erfunden, sondern sie haben es geschaffen.
Nein, sie haben es höchstens gefunden.
Was die Idee betrifft, aber nicht unbedingt, was die konkrete Ausarbeitung dieser Idee in der Realität wahrnehmen war.
Ein 400-seitiges Buch fliegt ja nicht eben mal so zu.
Also im Internet schon.
Na ja, aber dazu, es ist ja vorher auch explizit geschaffen worden und nicht nur gefunden worden, weil das würde ja voraussetzen, dass alle jemals irgendwo erstellten Bücher einfach nur so aus Tropfsteinhöhlen herauskullern.
Aber ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass das mit den Tropfsteinhöhlen ja im Moment ohnehin nicht so verbreitet ist, ist es doch so, dass auch ein Buchautor, der kommt ja nicht zur Welt und schreibt ein Buch, sondern der unterhält sich ja mit Millionen von Leuten möglicherweise, bevor das Buch schreibt, der liest andere Bücher, der klaut sich Gedanken anderer Leute am Laufenden Meter. Das ist das, was Menschen die ganze Zeit tun. Und dann irgendwie kombiniert hat das, was...
Die Gedanken sind ja auch frei, das ist ja auch okay.
Ja, und dann schreibt er das irgendwie auf und verwendet dabei sicherlich auch Formulierungen anderer Leute und so weiter und fort sagt, aber das ist jetzt sein. Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wir trennen doch jetzt bitte gleich von vornherein zwischen Idee und Werk, das ist halt relativ wichtig. Ich meine, das mit der Idee, das stimm ich dir auch absolut zu. Da gibt es halt diesen garstigen Begriff, Intellectual Property. Also es gibt sozusagen etwas, was mir gehört und das ist ein intellektuelles Gut. Das kommt irgendwie aus meiner Zellen-Konglomeration, die ich da oben in meinem Schädel durch die Gegend trage den ganzen Tag. Das kommt so herausgefallen.
Hast du eigentlich auch Haschesteuer?
Haschesteuer?
Worauf?
Auf den Verbrauch oder?
Aufs Anbauen.
Anbausteuer?
Nein, ich meine, die Leute, die es dir erlauben, dass dein Gehirn so gut funktioniert.
Ja, da wollte ich ja nun gerade zukommen, was sozusagen dazu führt. Also gehen wir einfach mal davon aus, mein Hirn funktioniert. Nehmen wir an, mein Hirn funktioniere, gesetzt sei, und dann käme es von Zeit zu Zeit vor, dass es bestimmte Ausgaben erzeugt. Und das Erste, was ich irgendwie über Computer gelernt habe, war die einfache Lehre, dass das mit den Computern im Prinzip nur auf dem simplen System der Eingabe, Verarbeitung und Ausgabe beruht, also kurz EFA, mit der kleinen Abschleifung, dass ja auch in der Bibel das schon irgendwie der Anfang aller Probleme war. Und dieses EFA-System findet bei mir halt statt. Mit anderen Worten, keine Ausgabe ohne Eingabe. Sicherlich bin ich für die Verarbeitung zuständig, aber das Endprodukt wäre sozusagen ohne die Eingabe nicht möglich. Man könnte also auch sagen, dass eine Idee niemals wirklich nur mein eigenes Eigentum ist, weil das würde ja voraussetzen, dass alles das, was zur Erzeugung dieser Idee beigetragen hat, in mir selber entstanden ist.
Was hältst du denn von der Theorie, dass die Eingaben ja nicht nur deine Ausgabe bestimmen, sondern dich sogar programmieren? Also eigentlich, wenn du jetzt sagst, du hast irgendwie etwas geschaffen und das war jetzt irgendwie deine Leistung aufgrund der Eingaben, die dir gemacht wird, dann würde ich sagen, ja, aber deine Mutter hat eigentlich einen überproportionalen Anteil der Lizenzgebühren zu bekommen, weil sie dich überproportional viel geprägt, sprich programmiert hat.
Ist richtig, also im Prinzip hat halt jeder von uns...
Ist das bei der VG Bord auch vorgesehen?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ja, aber jetzt kommen wir doch auf eine unserer schönen Thesen, die wir beim letzten Dienstag uns so voluminös um die Ohren geschmissen haben, dass wir das Ganze auch hätten einfach mitschneiden können und als Splatter-Movie auf dem Internet vertreiben können. So, dass es eigentlich ein Unding ist, dass man eine Idee für sich in Anspruch nimmt. Es mag ja sein, dass man als besonders klug oder intellektuell oder intelligent vielleicht sogar gilt. Ja, und dann alle sehr dankbar sind, dass irgendjemand eine Idee gehabt hat, aber letztlich ist es anmaßend davon zu behaupten, es wäre jetzt mein Eigentum mit all diesen assoziierten Rechten wie du darfst dieses Eigentum jetzt nicht entwenden oder vielleicht auch nicht betreten.
Die Ideengeschichte ist übrigens in Deutschland durch das Patentrecht geregelt, für was nun mal ein ganz anderes Kapitel für sich ist.
Nein, ist es nicht, weil es geht auch davon aus, dass du ein Eigentum deklarieren kannst. Das ist doch genau dasselbe.
Ja, das Patentrecht ist dazu da, um Sachen zu schützen, die eben nicht...
Ja, aber wir reden hier gerade über die Eigentumssrage und du redest davon, was für unterschiedliche Gesetze es gibt, die das Eigentum regeln und ich sage, es gibt überhaupt keine.
Nein, nein, nein, Ideen regeln, zunächst einmal. Also unabhängig davon, dass diese Rechtslage sagt, das Ei ein Eigentum, ist es überhaupt erst einmal eine, die Ideen betrifft. Bitte fahren Sie fort, Herr, mit beiden, bitte.
Das Schöne dabei ist, wenn wir da getrennte Gesetze haben, ist, dass wir das eine von den anderen unabhängig abschaffen können oder modifizieren können. Das ist sehr praktisch. Das heißt also, dieses Patentrecht ist, wie also die Patentierung von Genen irgendwie zeigt, von menschlichen Genen unter Umständen extrem schwachsinnig. Oder zumindest nicht unserer, der allgemeinen Ethik entsprechend.
Es gibt doch vor allem jede Menge Patente, die nur dazu da sind, damit die Dinge nicht gebaut werden. Es gibt zum Beispiel sogenannte Sperrpatente, nennt man das denn, wenn die Automobilindustrie in welche Pakte mit den Mineralölkonzernen schließt und sagt, na die nächsten 20 Jahre kann man ruhig noch Motoren verkaufen, die irgendwie mehr als 5 Liter verbrauchen, weil ist ja noch genug Asche zu machen mit dem Mineralöl.
Gut, aber darüber streiten wir ja im Prinzip gar nicht, da sind wir ja der Meinung, dass du das denkst.
Nö, darüber streiten wir sehr wohl, weil das hängt alles miteinander zusammen. Wenn es keine Patente gäbe, weil das kein geistiges Eigennuss gäbe, dann könnte jeder die Dinger bauen, wie er will.
Wir können uns ja einfach noch mal ein paar Minuten widersprechen.
Wir können auch einfach sagen, dass Ideen einfach nicht schutzfähig sind und auch nicht geschützt werden dürfen.
Ja, aber eine Idee ist ja niemals nur eine Idee. Also, wenn ich einen Gedanken habe und ihn niemandem mitteile, ja, aber in dem Moment, wo ich ihn ausspreche, wo ich zum Beispiel einen Vortrag halte und meine Ideen irgendwie anderen Menschen kommuniziere, ist das dann ein Werk, wenn ich einen Vortrag halte? Und das heißt, dass meine Worte, die ich ausspreche und die Anordnung meiner Worte, die ist geschützt, aber der Sinn meiner Worte natürlich nicht.
Richtig.
Gut, und wenn...
Es sei denn, du hast jetzt eine besondere Logik in deinem Erzählsystem, die du dir patentieren lassen möchtest?
Ja, da müsste ich dann wiederum steuern, nach wohin, kann ich sagen.
Wenn du feststellst, dass es irgendwie den Zuhörern extrem eingehämmert wird, wenn du in jedem zweiten Satz da-da-da-da sagst und du stellst fest, das ist irgendwie extrem Märklichkeitsfördernd, dann kannst du das möglicherweise patentieren lassen.
Evangelisten werden auf solche Ideen noch kommen, wenn sie es nicht schon sind.
Wolfgang Neuss hat das ganz kurz formuliert. Mich kann man nicht beklauen, mich kann man nur benutzen.
Was hat er damit gemeint?
Er hat seine Idee in der Welt geschenkt.
Ja, das ist auch gut so.
Das sollten eigentlich auch alle anderen tun.
Ja, die Frage ist ja die, dass wenn ich jetzt sage, alles was ich tue ist sozusagen Copy left oder auch Copy what you like. Macht doch einfach mit den Gedanken, mit den musischen Dingern einfach was ihr wollt, aber dann kommen irgendwelche Arschlöcher daher und deklarieren das als ihr es und beharren darauf, dass sie jetzt der Eigentumsrecht sind. Das heißt, sie eignen sich etwas an, was eigentlich allen gehört. Das heißt ja auch Privatäre dem Allgemeinen wohl entziehen. Also Eigentum ist per se Diebstahl. Aber das Urheberrecht manifestiert das ja. Das heißt, es erlaubt doch. Moment mal kurz. Das Urheberrecht schützt nicht den öffentlichen Raum vor Entwendung von Werken aus dem öffentlichen Raum und Deklarierung von Eigentumsrechten. Das tut es eben nicht zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt. Es gibt den Begriff öffentlichen Raum in deinem dicken Buch, was du da vor dir liegen hast, wo Urheber- und Verlagsrecht drauf steht, einfach mal nicht. Oder? Er sagt doch mal. Er sagt doch mal. Hier, Alter, Laden. Den öffentlichen Raum. Ja, den öffentlichen Raum. Hier, das Ding, wo wir hier gerade reinsprechen, zum Beispiel. In die Hirne dieser Leute da. Wenn sie noch nicht abgeschaltet haben. So ist der öffentliche Raum, okay? Ist der Public Space Laden.
Ja, und wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Da ist ein Problem, Lan East. Wenn ich jetzt hier, wir machen hier gerade Musik spielen. Wir müssen hier mal kurz sein.
Wir müssen mal die Lokal-Geste kussieren.
Vielleicht scheinen wir einfach mal von dem öffentlichen Raum aus dem dritten Raum um.
Wir unterbrechen kurz dieses musikalische Programm hier. Ich hab den falschen Knopf gedrückt, weil mal da, so jetzt. Ich hab schon gedacht, warum klingt das hier alles so komisch? Na ja, gut, also 22.30 Uhr.
Fritz Kurzinfo.
Ja, das Wetter nachts um 10 Grad, tagsüber dann wechselhaft mit Schauern bei bis zu 24 Grad. Die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Henrich.
Arbeitgeber und Gewerkschaften wollen mit gemeinsamen Aktionen gegen den Rechtsextremismus vorgehen. Beide Organisationen kündigten an, in den Betrieben und in der Öffentlichkeit gezielt über die Gefahr von Rechts aufzuklären. Die Umstände einer 100.000 Mark-Spende des Waffenhändlers Schreiber an die CDU sind weiter unklar. Der ehemalige Parteichef Schäuble und die frühere Schatzmeisterin Baumeister blieben vor dem Untersuchungsausschuss zur Finanzaffäre bei ihren Aussagen. Beide erklärten, das Geld selbst entgegengenommen und an den jeweils anderen weitergegeben zu haben. Die Deutsche Angestellten-Gewerkschaft lehnt eine Änderung des Ladenschlussgesetzes ab. Sie reagierte damit auf den Vorstoß der Bundesländer, die für Werktage erweiterte Öffnungszeiten von 6 bis 22 Uhr für den Samstag... Bitte was? Ach, für Werktagen von 6 bis 22 Uhr und für den Samstag bis 20 Uhr anstreben. Das muss man ja mal klar verstehen hier. An Sonn- und Feiertagen sollen die Daten in der Regel geschlossen bleiben. Bei dem Brand im Moskau-Fernsehturm sind vier Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Ihre Leichen wurden in einem abgestürzten Fahrstuhl gefunden. Das Feuer ist inzwischen weitgehend gelöscht. Und eine Sportmeldung noch. Der 1. FC Kaiserslautern hat nach einem 4 zu 0-Sieg bei Kickers Offenbach die zweite Runde im DFB-Pokal erreicht.
Verkehr?
Habe ich keinen.
Ach, das war wunderbar. Vielen Dank, Gerald. 22 Uhr. Ihr Arschgeigen. 22.32 Uhr.
Am 1. September ist es soweit.
Der Wettbewerb für Leute, die für Hip-Hop und so weiter. Findet statt mit großer Bühne in der Admiralstraße am Cottbuser Tor.
Und auf der Bühne DJs und MCs.
Und Kauner aus Berlin.
Vor der Bühne?
Vier.
Der große Rap-Contest am Cottbuser Tor in Berlin-Kreuzberg. Freitag, 1.
September, 17 Uhr. Übrigens, wenn Hip-Hop satt und laut, dann jeden Dienstag um 20 Uhr im Soundgarden mit André Langenfeld.
Also wir waren das Chaosradio, ja Fritz, ab und zu müssen wir uns ja auch mal sagen, ob ihr wisst, was hier passiert.
Chaosradio 53, die Freiheit der Witz und die Unmöglichkeit geistigen Eigentums. Und wir waren auf dem Weg, jetzt musst du diesen Knopf da drücken, wo dann diese Ansage kommt. Sozialromantik.
Du musst jetzt zwischendurch auch mal Dududududu sagen, damit das auch...
Ja stimmt, Dudududu hat er auch gesagt. Und Kommunist.
Sozialromantischer Kommunist Dududu.
Was ist eigentlich der öffentliche Raum?
Du musst noch näher ans Mikrofon ran.
Ja, wir waren ganz kurz, aber das war glaube ich vorhin auch weiter aufgedreht. Wir waren ganz kurz bei der Unterscheidung zwischen Ideen und Werken, die halt dieses Recht theoretisch macht. Und dann sagt man immer so schön, ja die Ideen, die Gedanken, die sind ja frei. Aber die Werke, die müssen geschützt werden. Und dem würde ich jetzt einfach mal insofern widersprechen wollen, als dass ja auch, genauso wie es eben das kollektive Unterbewusstsein gibt, in dem diese freien Gedanken sich so entwickeln, so wabern, von irgendwelchen Menschen gedacht werden, von anderen dann ausgesprochen werden, eben auch die Werke wiederum Produkte sind, die letztendlich aus dem öffentlichen Raum stehen. Das ist soweit auch alles okay, also aus dem kollektiven Unterbewusstsein kommen. Das ist nur in dem Moment nicht mehr okay, wo jemand sagt, das gehört jetzt mir. Und dann Kontrollrechte beansprucht auf etwas, was eigentlich allen gehört. Weil in dem Moment ist es weder Kommunismus noch Sozialismus, noch macht es irgendwie Spaß, sondern es ist Spießerscheiße. Und führt dazu, dass wir uns auf einmal mit Juristen auseinandersetzen müssen, mit Leuten, die Krawatten tragen, die uns das Internet sensieren wollen, und mit dem ganzen anderen Kram. War das jetzt klar und verkürzt, präzise zusammen?
Das war sehr verkürzt.
Ja gut, habe ich jetzt irgendwas vergessen, was wesentlich ist?
Na ja, du hast schon vergessen, dass dir eine Idee vielleicht einfach zufliegen kann, aber ein Werk eben nicht plötzlich aus dem Nichts entsteht, oder aus dem kollektiven Raum entsteht, einfach kein Werk draus, sondern es gibt einen konkreten, der diese Idee aufnimmt und irgendwie ausarbeitet.
Also wenn viele Omis sich zusammenhocken und untereinander Stickmuster per Computer austauschen, dann werden auch neue Werke der Überlieferung entstehen, aber irgendwie, wenn da einer anfängt, ich bin der Erfinder der Stickens, und jeder, der stickt, ohne meine Lizenz zu haben, ab in den Knast, auch die Omis, also das ist nur nicht der Weg.
Wenn man sich die Menschheitgeschichte so anguckt, ich meine, wir haben am Dienstag darüber diskutiert, wie ist denn das mit den Pythagoras und den Geschichten mit dem Dreieck so. Klar, wir nennen das Zeug immer noch Pythagoras, aber wir zahlen dem Mann noch sein Erben eine Lizenzgebühr, und jeder, der darauf in Wien ein Patent haben will, dann würden wir auch sagen, also schon mal ganz viele andere Sachen basieren da drauf und sind eine Weiterentwicklung. Aber so ist das doch mit allem. Alles ist doch eine weiterentwicklungsfähige Sache. Und alles wird auch ständig weiterentwickelt. Bloß diejenigen, die sagen, das ist jetzt aber meins, die behindern diesen Prozess. Das heißt, die behindern Evolution, also weg mit denen.
Also ich wäre schon halbwegs glücklich, wenn vom Weltkulturerbe alles im Netz frei zur Verfügung steht, von allen Leuten, die mehr als 70 Jahre tot sind. Dann spart man sich eine ganze Menge fürchterlich aufgeblähten modernen Müll und hat ein gutes Sortiment.
Aber dafür zahlt man.
Ja, dazu braucht man Geld. Das kostet.
Ja, aber es gibt auch Leute, die würden, wenn sie das abrufen könnten, so wie du, die würden ja auch darin einen Wert sehen. Also erstmal, der Wert hat nichts mit Geld zu tun, sondern ein Wert schaffen heißt, zum Beispiel, wenn ich ein Werk schaffe, das bisher nur ein Gedanke war, wenn Tim zum Beispiel so T-Shirts macht, irgendwie, sie können den Computer jetzt wegwerfen, in diesem Originalschriftzug zu. Dann hat er damit ein Werk geschafft, das kann man auch anfassen, das kann man ihm auch klauen, das kann man auch verkaufen, aber erstmal ist es nur, ja nur ein Logo. So, und das ist ja ein Wert, das man jetzt mal sieht und nicht nur darüber spricht. Aber wenn jetzt der PC...
Schwert oder ein Werk?
Werk. Ich meine, wenn du das irgendwie malst, dann sitzt ja auch irgendwie, dein Computer musste mal jemand erfinden und bezahlen und so weiter und so fort. So, und jetzt haben wir also dieses Werk und das stellt ein Wert dar. Aber nicht unbedingt ein Geldwert, sondern das ist einfach klasse, dass du das gemacht hast. Das finden wir gut. Wir amüsieren uns darüber. Das heißt, der Wert besteht darin, dass du die Kulturgemeinschaft um einen Werk bereichert hast.
Und bist du der Meinung, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche Rechte daran haben soll?
Ich meine, du hast es zumindest gemacht und wir werden sicherlich glücklich erwähnen, dass du das gemacht hast. Die Ehre steht dir schon zu.
Und wenn jemand anders damit jetzt auch T-Shirts macht, was ist das dann?
Ja, dann macht er damit T-Shirts. Dann steht ihm irgendwie die Ehre zu, dass er T-Shirts machen. Und die Frage ist, hast du das tatsächlich erfunden? Hast du das gefunden? Ich meine, kann ich die Geschichte zurückverfolgen?
Die Frage ist überhaupt, ob das ein Werk ist.
Es war eine göttliche Eingebung.
Eine göttliche Eingebung, alles klar.
Tja, das ist die Frage, ob es ein Werk ist. Letztlich war es die Idee von anderen Leuten.
Ist das nicht immer?
Wow, könntest du bitte das Mikrofon ein bisschen dichter an deinen Mund rannehmen?
Könnte man eventuell auch die Worte...
Ja, besser schützen.
Gut, also wenn wir uns da einig sind, dann können wir jetzt einig sein.
Naja, es gibt natürlich eine ganze Menge Leute, die das nicht so sehen. Ich gehöre da jetzt nicht unbedingt dazu. Aber das sollten wir schon nochmal erwähnen, dass das ja eine der Problematiken ist in dem Bereich. Dass Leute, die einmal irgendwas erfunden haben, also ein Werk geschaffen haben und das vielleicht auch mit einer Idee, die sie dazu gebracht hat, dieses Werk genau so auszuführen, wie sie es getan haben, dass sie daran halt für sich ein Recht sehen an diesem Werk oder eben auch vielleicht an dieser Idee. Das einfache Ding bezieht sich halt immer aufs Werk. Da ist dann das Urheberrecht zuständig. So nach dem Motto, das ist jetzt mein Werk und ich darf bestimmen, in welchem Kontext das überhaupt benutzt wird. Ich darf bestimmen, wo es erscheint oder wo es nicht erscheint.
Moment, wo kommen jetzt ganz kurz deine...
Ich rede nur von der Realität, Andi. Die gibt es ja auch noch. Und da draußen sitzen eine ganze Menge Leute, die machen das halt genauso. Ich meine, wenn wir irgendwie jetzt nochmal drauf gehtweisen...
Ich will dir nur eine Frage stellen.
Was denn?
Die Frage ist, wenn du sagst, du stellst daran in Anspruch, dass du das warst, okay, wenn da steht irgendwie, das ist von dem gemacht, habe ich kein Problem damit. Auch in der Wissenschaft und auch in Islam, wo es übrigens kein Copyright gibt, ist es halt üblich, jemandem Credit zu geben, sagt man dazu. Also wenn jemand irgendwie einen tollen Gedanken hat und den entwickelt man weiter, dann zitiert man ihn damit. So, und ich habe auch überhaupt kein Problem damit, dich damit zu zitieren. Aber jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, als nächstes kommt denn, ich will darüber bestimmen können. Wo kommt denn jetzt auf einmal diese bestimmerische, ich meine, vielleicht hast du solche Gene, aber...
Ich habe ja gerade gesagt, dass ich zusammenfassend nicht meine eigene Meinung wiedergebe, sondern dass ich sozusagen versuche zu beschreiben, was da draußen unter anderem auch getan wird. Im Übrigen derzeit in der Mehrheit.
Ja, ey, die haben auch Sex mit Kühen da draußen.
Ich meine, in der Mehrheit.
Also ich glaube, so weit sind wir noch nicht.
Die Frage ist ja, was passiert, wenn du einen gewissen Aufwand hattest, irgendwie dieses Werk zu erschaffen. Wenn du dafür zum Beispiel ein Jahr lang irgendwie gearbeitet hast und ein Buch geschrieben hast, das viel Zeit hat. Dann ist es doch nur legitim, dass ich zumindest probieren kann, diesen Wert zurückzubekommen.
Ja, das ist völlig legitim. Aber die Frage ist nur durch, den Wert. Du hast sehr schön Wert gesagt, du hast nicht gesagt...
Dieser Wert ist in diesem Fall irgendwie 40.000 Mark, um jetzt irgendwie ein Jahr...
Ja, es gibt Bücher, da bekommt der Auto 400 Mark dafür, dass es geschrieben wird. Es gibt andere, da kriegt er 400.000 dafür. Aber da gibt es dann schon...
Moment, das ist ja nicht ganz richtig. Er kriegt das ja nicht dafür, sondern er bestimmt diesen Wert sozusagen.
Nee, das ist leider nicht möglich. Also wenn du heute zu einem Buchverleger gehst und sagst, gib mir 5 Millionen Mark, ich habe ein Buch geschrieben, dann zeige ich dir entweder, wo der Ausgang ist, oder er sagt irgendwie...
Ist deine Frage damit beantwortet?
Nein, weil wir hier gerade zwei Sachen durcheinander bringen, nämlich die Finanzierung von Künstlern und die Schaffung von Werten.
Wir bringen noch eine ganze Menge Sachen durcheinander, wie ich finde.
Ich wollte die an einem vereinfachten Beispiel zusammenbringen, nämlich wenn ich mir Amseln anhöre, wie die singen, dann haben die Altvögel auch Aufwand mit dem Aufzucht der Brut und hinterher singt die Brut dann das Gleiche auch noch nach.
Das ist ja das Allerletzte.
Also die nächste Möglichkeit wäre dann, dass in dieser Population dann Kampf-Amseln entstehen, die dafür sorgen, dass die anderen nicht die gleiche Melodie singen.
Solange die keine Zitizien davon verkaufen?
Ja, aber wo ist der Unterschied?
Wovon reden wir?
Wir reden davon, dass Lebewesen Gehirne haben. Und Lebewesen haben Gehirne. Diese Gehirne sind mit dem kollektiven Unterbewusstsein mit Gott oder wie ihr es auch immer nennen verbunden. Und deswegen sind diese Lebewesen in der Lage, weil sie auch noch Sprachorgane haben und weil sie Flossen haben und alle diese Dinge, die sie steuern können, aus diesen kollektiven Wabern dann irgendetwas, ob man jetzt gläubig ist oder nicht, etwas zu machen, was man auch anfassen kann, zum Beispiel oder was man lesen kann, eben Buchstaben auf dem Lattpapier oder Musik, die eben dann durch den Mund ausbrechen kann oder auf eine CD aufnehmen kann. Ob die Amseln jetzt CDs aufnehmen oder nicht, ist doch kein Unterschied.
Ich würde das Thema gerne mal etwas von den Amseln wegbewegen in den humanoiden Bereich, weil einfach im humanen Bereich sich die Leute mehr über so rechtliche Details Gedanken machen.
Ja, aber bloß weil Anselne intelligentere Wesen sind, die keine Juristen unterhalten.
Guten Abend, hier ist das Chaosradio 53. Andi, sag doch nochmal, du hast eben so schön in einem Satz gesagt, worüber wir versuchen zu reden.
Ganz, ganz. Oder wir reden einfach mal darüber, ob wir das mit dem geistigen Eigentum jetzt nicht mal sein lassen, und uns auf die relevanten Fragen konfrontieren. Nämlich, wo kriegen die Amseln zu Fressen? Wer verpasst ihnen gute Bildung? Wie sieht es aus mit dem Nestbau? Und wo kriegen sie um unnützwillen auch was zu ficken her?
Ja, warum sollten wir uns das jetzt aber fragen? Also das wollte ich eigentlich damit, dass du sagst, worüber wir reden. Also wir reden über Urheberrecht, so im weitesten Sinne, oder?
Entschuldigung, ja, richtig. Also wir reden über die Frage, ob sozusagen eine ältere Amsel, die ihren Kindern etwas vorsingt, oder überhaupt die älteren Amseln, ob die eben entsprechende geistige Eigentumsrechte an diesem Gesang haben und dann Lizenzgebühren daran haben können, und ob dann nicht sogar Kampf-Amseln, oder wir haben es, glaube ich, eben Amselkontrollkampf, ne, wie haben wir die Dinger genannt? Ist ja auch wurscht, wie wir es genannt haben. Wenn man die Rollrechte natürlich erhebt, dann muss man die auch durchsetzen. Das heißt, dann muss man dann auch irgendwann die Männer mit der Maschine gewähren und die Amselkontrolle zeigen.
Das Schöne dabei ist aber, dass die Gedanken schon Leute ganz lange vor uns gemacht haben.
Warte mal, jetzt einfach mal für blöde. Es geht ja eigentlich darum, Musiker macht Lied, Musiker gibt Lied weiter, alle dürfen es benutzen, kopieren, verteilen, wovon kriegt Musiker seine Arbeit bezahlt?
Genau, wie sieht es mit Happy Happy für Künstler aus? Und wie können wir auch dafür sorgen, dass...
Dass er was zu ficken hat?
Naja, ich meine, das ist dann wieder eine andere Diskussion.
Weil es bei den Amsen im Musikbereich auch das geringste Problem ist, was wir im Moment im Gedanken machen müssten.
Vielen Dank.
Bitteschön.
Lass uns doch mal ein bisschen so konkret... Ja, ich bin in den Medien, du, wir sehen uns in den Medien. Lass uns das doch mal konkret am Künstler irgendwie versuchen, festzumachen, weil das mit den Amsen ist. Es ist zwar hübsch, aber kannst du mir einen klumpen Ton geben. Wenn du den nimmst? Nehmen wir mal Smudo.
Also Smudo hat irgendwie schöpft aus dem kollektiven Unterbewusstsein und Smudo wird geprägt von seiner Umwelt und wird von lauter Leuten zugetextet seit seiner Kindheit und ist deswegen in einer bestimmten Art und Weise programmiert. Jetzt sitzt er sich mit ein paar anderen Jungs in ein Studio und da laufen Bandmaschinen und da stehen Instrumente rum und irgendwer bezahlt das Studio auch und die hämmern da also irgendwie rum und lallen da irgendwie in irgendwelche Maschinen und tun irgendwelche Dinge, die man als kreativ bezeichnen könnte und da kommt immer was dabei raus. Das was dabei rauskommt ist also irgendwie, sagen wir erstmal, ein Dat oder was weiß ich was. Naja, ob das Musik ist, haben wir alles dahingestellt, aber es ist irgendwie etwas so. Es ist eine Anordnung von Bits. Und da dieser ganze Produktionsprozess, eben weil das Studio hat Geld gekostet, die Jungs konnten währenddessen nicht den Abwasch anderswo machen und konnten auch nicht anderen Leuten irgendwie gerade Häuser bauen. Das heißt, irgendwer muss halt ihre Miete bezahlen und so fort. Jetzt gibt es ja irgendwie einen bestimmten Betrag, der in der theoretischen Raume steht, die die Aktion jetzt de facto gekostet hat. Und eigentlich müssen sie sich vorher natürlich auch überlegt haben, wo soll denn die Kohle herkommen. Aber nehmen wir mal an, dieser Smudo, den würde überhaupt keiner kennen. Das ist also total eine neue Angelegenheit. Und jetzt haben sie eigentlich nur 500.000 Mark Schulden oder so. Tja, und jetzt können sie das Ganze auf eine CD pressen. Was sie im Moment machen ist, sie geben es einer Verwertungsgesellschaft. Ja, gut, etwas neutraler. Etwas neutraler. Ah ja, ein Label. Blabla. In einer Plattenfirma, die presst dann daraus irgendwie Dinger. Und diese Dinger, die kosten dann eben Geld.
Genau, und von diesem Geld gehen zum Beispiel zwei Mark oder drei Mark irgendwie an die Fantasie.
Genau. Und damit dieser Laden aber diese Plastik-Dinger überhaupt verkauft, müssen sie erstmal Plakate drucken und was nicht alles. Das kostet auch Geld. Da sind wir schon ganz schnell bei einer Million Mark Schulden. Und irgendwie trägt sich das dann wieder rein. Und keine Ahnung, vielleicht hat Smudo irgendwas falsch gemacht. Jedenfalls hat man den Eindruck, er ist gerade an der Leine dieser Industrie. Wahrscheinlich hat er Schulden.
Ich meine, ich fände Smudo doch nicht so ein gutes Beispiel. Er ist ein bisschen geprägt, weil der junge Mann da ziemlich klare Einstellungen nach außen trägt, was dieses ganze Copyright...
Aber was heißt da eine Einstellung? Ich meine, ich finde es de facto erst mal nicht so zu widerlegen.
Das, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist ja auch einfach nur der Ist-Zustand. Aber jetzt nehmen wir mal an, Smudo würde also sein Kram immer noch im Studio an diese Mikrofone grünen und so fort. Und wir hätten immer noch dieses Werk. Und das Werk würden wir jetzt, wie wir es auch immer nennen, ins Internet packen und alle können darauf zugreifen. Und keiner würde dafür erst mal bezahlen müssen, weil es nämlich kein Kontroll- und kein Eigentumsrecht gibt. Aber es gibt immer noch diese 500.000 Mark, die wieder zusammenkommen müssen. Das Marketing haben wir uns jetzt mal gespart. Und es gibt die, ja, ich zahle dem Künstler eine Mark-Taste. Und diejenigen, die das cool finden, die wissen alle, da steht auf der Website steht dieser Betrag. Das wird jeden Tag von Berners ein paar Mark mehr. Aber der muss irgendwie zusammenkommen. Oder die Jungs müssen halt alle erbärmlich viele Teller abwaschen gehen, damit sie keine Schulden haben.
Okay, das heißt also, damit geht das Risiko von der Plattenfirma auf die Fantastischen Vier über. Das Risiko des Misserfolges.
Ja, aber ich hab doch, Entschuldigung Frank, ich hab aber doch keine Lust, also ich hab keine Lust für das Risiko extra Geld zu zahlen im Laden. Und das tue ich ja, indem das Risiko bei der Plattenfirma ist.
Genau.
Und was soll das?
Eben, und ich meine, wenn die...
Vielleicht ist ja die Band ganz glücklich darüber.
Ja, aber sorry, die Band, die macht doch die Musik nicht, um sich daran zu bereichern, sondern die macht die doch, um die Leute zu erfreuen. Das ist das, was sie immer behaupten. Und dann können sie aber auch ruhig das Risiko tragen. Weil, hey, da kann ich doch ganz klasse in den Spiegel schauen morgens, wenn ich auch noch das Risiko trage, daran, dass ich Leute erfreuen will und kein Geld oder nicht reich damit werden will.
Es geht als Verleger auch andersrum. Der Werner Pieper hat ein Lebensabo und bei einem Abo erwartet man das Unerwartete. Und auch dafür kann man einfach bezahlen. Eine der letzten kleinen Broschüren, die von ihm rausgekommen ist, heißt einen Vertrag kann man nicht spielen. Und schildert die Situation eines Musikers, wie er in der Frühzeit der mechanischen Vervielfältigung in den USA lebte und mit anderen zusammen jammte und Sachen machte und dann plötzlich hieß es, diese Takte sind eingekreist und gehören jemand anders, die darfst du nicht mehr spielen. Und vorher wurden diese Takte von der Gemeinschaft der Musiker einfach entwickelt und ausgeschmückt und verändert, so wie meinetwegen Märchen auf einer anderen Ebene. Also wie es bei Texten auch geht. Und beim Verleger-Verband habe ich das mitgekriegt, die haben da die ganz harte Auffassung, früher gab es Leib-Eigene, heute gibt es Geisteigene. Das heißt, das sind die Lohnschreiber der Zeitung, die von den Verlegern bezahlt werden, dafür, dass sie Texte abliefern. Und die Texte gehören dann den Verlegern, denn die haben den Menschen ja gekauft und sein Leben finanziert. Also was will er denn da noch, mein Untertan? Das amerikanische Copyright sagt, gehört ihm, der dafür bezahlt. Und das europäische, also da will er in den Manteltarif-Vereinbarungen dann noch einen Zusatzausgleich zum Lohn, weil der Text nicht nur auf Papier gedruckt wird, sondern auch noch im Internet kommt. Was will er denn da von mir? Wir wollen hier amerikanische Copyright reden.
Ja, Moment, da musst du jetzt aber ein bisschen mit dem Maurer vergleichen. Der Maurer kriegt dafür Geld, dass er irgendwie ein Haus mauert. Und was wäre es, wenn der Maurer danach ankommt und sagt, ich hab dieses Haus gemauert, ich will da jetzt auch drin wohnen?
Du vergisst die leichte Kurierbarkeit.
Ja, Moment mal kurz. Also ich meine, der Maurer bekommt ja nicht nur dafür Geld, dass er das Haus gemauert hat, sondern auch, dass er das gelernt hat. Und bei Maurer ist der Akt jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so offensichtlich, aber beim Musiker ist ja auch die Erfahrung und so weiter sofort plus. In der Tat ist die Motivation die Frage. Und wenn ich in die Häuser klopfen gehe, dann ist es klar, dass ich nicht unbedingt nur Freude am Häuser klopfen habe. Ich weiß nicht, wobei die Jungs vielleicht auch Freude haben.
Sind wir jetzt eigentlich noch bei dem Punkt, wo wir mal erzählen wollen, wie wir meinen, die Künstler Geld kriegen?
Ja, wir sind immer noch bei der Frage, wäre nicht das Gedudel der Amseln sehr viel monotoner, wenn die Amseln Eigentumsrechte deklarieren würden, auf bestimmte Melodien teilen, würde nicht der öffentliche Raum darunter leiden? Und insofern, Bruce Schneier hat sich Gedanken gemacht, wie dann die Künstler finanziert werden könnten, in einer Welt, wo es einfach keine Kontrollrechte mehr gibt. Wer hat sich da Gedanken gemacht? Ein gewisser Bruce Schneier, das ist so ein Typ, der hat mal ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Applied Cryptography. Das ist eigentlich so eine Grundlagenvermittlung in relativ verständlichen Worten, was Verschlüsselungstechnologie ist. Und der Mann ist so was ähnliches wie ein angesehener Computersicherheitsspezialist, der sich, wie alle, die sich da ein bisschen mit beschäftigen, überhaupt keine Illusionen hin gibt und sagt, also die Zeiten, wo man Bits noch kontrollieren kann, das ist gelaufen. Das gibt es einfach nicht mehr, weil Computers sind auch gar nicht dazu gemacht worden, Bits irgendwie geheim zu halten oder irgendwas, sondern das sind eben Verarbeitungsmaschinen. Und er sagt eben auf der Annahme basierend, dass wir das mit den Kontrollrechten backen können, müssen wir aber trotzdem die Künstler ja noch finanzieren, weil wir wollen ja die Kunst, wir wollen ja die Musik. Und keine Ahnung, ich höre diese fanatischen Vier irgendwie nicht, aber wenn die irgendwie toll sind, dann wird es auch Leute geben, die da bereit sind, Geld für auszugeben. Ich bin das nicht, weil jemand, der solche Texte ins Internet verdreht, wie das Smudo, also von denen will ich auch keine Musik hören. Aber nee, echt, da versau ich mir doch mein Karma mit. Aber gut, das ist vielleicht eine andere Diskussion. Das ist eine andere Diskussion. Okay, also was der...
Moment mal, Moment mal, warte mal.
Ich unterbreche mal kurz, ich lasse mal eben ansagen, wie das hier heißt. Ist nämlich gleich 23 Uhr. Und zwar das Chaosradio Nr. 53. Wir versuchen über geistiges Eigentum zu reden. Im Studio sag ich auch mal, der Tim, der Andi. Ja, ich weiß, das war andersrum. Der Tim, der Andi, der Wau und der Frank. Sagt guten Tag Jungs.
Na Band.
Erstmal Musik hören.
Wollen wir nicht lieber die danach, wir wollen die danach glaube ich, oder?
Hat jemand irgendwie Beißhölzer dabei? Wir haben hier so ein akutes Problem.
Chaosradio 53 ist es hier. Schönen guten Abend. Wir reden über geistiges Eigentum und den Umgang mit diesem, beziehungsweise wie man vielleicht mit dem geistigen Eigentum besser umgehen kann, als es derzeit getan wird. Andi, ethisch, moralisch besser, wie auch immer. Also warte. Du guckst so grimmig.
Ich guck dich nur so grimmig an, weil ich dachte, wir hätten uns schon darauf geeinigt, dass es so was wie geistiges Eigentum einfach gar nicht mehr geben soll.
Stopp. Stopp. Also, was gibt es denn gerade? Können wir das vielleicht erstmal klären? Also, schön wäre, erstmal zu sagen, wenn ihr mir mal erklären würdet, wie ist es denn gerade?
Also, es ist gerade so, dass es ein Netz gibt, was Internet heißt. Und über das Internet ist es halt im Wesentlichen eine gemeinsame Sprache, sozusagen, die Computer miteinander sprechen und einen Adressraum und darauf aufbauend wiederum Dienste. Und das heißt, was da passiert ist, Partei A kann mit Partei B oder auch Computer A mit Computer B über Computer C Bits austauschen. Große Datenmengen, kleine Datenmengen, man kann auch auf Server C jede Menge Bitsanordnungen ablegen und da können dann ABC bis XYZ alle drauf zugreifen. Das passiert massig und weil es eben neue Übertragungsverfahren, zum Beispiel für Musik gibt, wie MP3, was eine auf psychoakustischen Modellen basierende Komprimierungsmethode ist, damit eben so eine CD, wie wir sie jetzt hier gerade hören, ne, das ist keine CD, keine Ahnung. Wir hören ja die ganze Zeit hier MP3s.
Das war mal eine CD.
Wir haben ja so ein Bit Recycling gemacht. Das heißt, wir haben uns die Bits von der CD genommen und die dann nach dem so genannten MP3-Verfahren kodiert oder in diesem Fall entkodiert, sagt man dazu. Und das heißt, bestimmte Bereiche, die das menschliche Ur sowieso nicht hört, das wurde so ein Test herausgefunden, sind hier einfach weggefallen. Dadurch nimmt es auf Tim seiner Festplatte nicht so viel Platz weg, weil die ist nämlich voll.
Also, wenn ich das mal kurz zusammenfassen darf, es gibt ein Copyright, was bisher Leuten ermöglicht hat, die Distribution rechtlich sozusagen verfolgen zu lassen, wenn sie nicht so läuft, wie man es selber möchte. Man hat das Kopierrecht. Man darf sagen, irgendwie so und so ist die Verwertung meines Werkes, wohin Deutschland zum Beispiel das Urheberrecht drauf zielt. In den USA gibt es dann noch diese spezielle Variante des Copyright. Das Copyright ist halt ein etwas zwielichtiges Gesetz geworden, weil das Kopieren mittlerweile so selbstverständlich und vor allem so einfach und das auch noch quer über den ganzen Planeten in wenigen Sekunden funktioniert.
Entscheidend ist ja nicht das Kopieren, sondern die Weitergabe und die Verbreitung.
Ja, Tatsache ist, es lässt sich halt nicht mehr kontrollieren. Also man kann jetzt viel darüber reden, dass das ja vielleicht jetzt in den letzten 50 oder 100 Jahren, seitdem es eben die Buchpresse gibt, also seit wann ist das? 1492 oder wann hat er das erfunden? Ich habe keine Ahnung. War das Amerika, was entdeckt wurde, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall hat der alte Gutenberg irgendwann mal so eine Buchdruckmaschine erfunden. Und als sie dann gemerkt haben, hoppala, wie einfach man jetzt hier kopieren kann, was vorher irgendwie, wo man irgendwie eine ganze Horde von Mönchen in irgendwelchen Klössern eingesperrt hat, damit die irgendwie ein paar Bücher wieder schreiben, war das alles nicht nennenswert. Aber mit der Buchdruckmaschine ging es halt schneller. Und jetzt haben wir halt wieder einen Schritt erreicht, der irgendwie den Fotokopierer einfach in den Schatten stellt. Und das ist das Internet. Und jetzt ist es halt der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo man sich mal fragen muss, ob denn das mit dem Copyright überhaupt von Anfang an eine gute Idee war. Und ob es nicht, ob diese Geschäftsmodelle, die heute existieren, die auf diesem Copyright basieren, dass es eben gibt, und auch theoretisch verfolgt werden kann, ob die jetzt nicht total überholt sind, weil sie generieren eine ganze Menge Stress. Da gibt es ein gutes Beispiel. Das kannst du ja vielleicht mal kurz zusammenfassen. In den USA mit dieser MPAA-Klage.
Gut, aber um nochmal ganz kurz den wesentlichen Punkt vielleicht festzuhalten, worum es geht, ist das, was den Stress macht, ist der Anspruch auf die Kontrollrechte. Das heißt, das, was eben jetzt nicht mehr geht, ist, dass man überhaupt noch Kontrolle ausübt, weil die Bits fließen nun mal. Und das Rechtssystem basiert aber immer noch auf der Annahme, dass es Kontrolloptionen gibt. Gut, wenn jetzt jemand Telepathie findet, dann gibt es da noch weitaus komplexere Probleme. Das lassen wir jetzt mal außen vor. Es gibt jetzt gerade in Amerika ein Verfahren, was sehr, sehr viel Beachtung innerhalb der HK-Szene gefunden hat. Da hat die MPAA, die Motion Pictures of America Association, das ist der Verband der Filmindustrie, also Warner Brothers und Disney und wie sie alle heißen, hat verklagt, die 2600, das ist so was wie unsere Schwesterzeitschrift dort, wegen Verbreitung bzw. Verlinkung des sogenannten DCSS Source Codes. DCSS ist das Content Scambling System bzw. De-Content Scambling, also Decoding Content Scambling System, der Digital Video Disk, was soviel heißt, wie diese DVDs, die die Videokassette ablösen sollen.
Es ist der Verschlüsselungsmechanismus von DVDs, wollte ich sagen.
Genau, das wollte ich sagen. Und dieser Verschlüsselungsmechanismus, der basiert im Moment darauf, dass man, wenn man z.B. in Amerika eine DVD kauft, dann kann man die nicht etwa in Europa abspielen. Nein, das ist nicht richtig. Na ja, das kann man schon. Du bringst jetzt zwei Sachen durcheinander. Ja, ich bringe zwei Sachen durcheinander. Aber es gibt jedenfalls eine Lizensierungsjuristische Modellierung, die sich wiederum in einer Technik manifestiert. Und die bedeutet, dass A, DVDs nur abspielen kann, wer eine Lizenz hat und wer eben das entschlüsseln kann. Und B, dass er bei der Erfüllung dieser Lizenzbedingungen auch z.B. auf den sogenannten Region-Code Rücksicht nehmen muss, weil nämlich die Filmindustrie ganz kontrollierte Absatzmärkte hat, wo sie sagt, die und die, in den und den Ländern darf der und der nur DVDs verkaufen und in den in den Ländern nur der und der. Damit das nicht durcheinandergeht, damit z.B. die Chinesen, Japaner oder Islamisten oder wer auch immer jede Menge Raubkopien machen.
Der Region-Code hat nichts mit der Verschlüsselung zu tun.
Doch, der hat was damit zu tun. Lass es noch mal ganz gesagt. Also wir hatten früher VHS, Videokassetten. Da konnten wir von Amerika nach Europa schiffen. Total egal, da gab es noch Pala und Seekam-Unterschiede. Aber es gibt Multinorm-Recorder. im Grunde genommen kannst du alles überall gucken. Mit DVDs ist das jetzt anders. Weil DVDs enthalten den Inhalt verschlüsselt. Und derjenige, der ein Entschlüsselungsgerät, nämlich ein DVD-Player mit der dazugehörigen Software oder auch ein Standalone-Gerät auf den Markt bringen will, muss ein Lizenzabkommen unterzeichnen. Und erst dann bekommt er mitgeteilt, wie man das entschlüsseln kann. Damit er das aber darf, muss er bestimmte Bedingungen des Lizenzvertreis erfüllen. Zum Beispiel muss er den Region-Code, das heißt den Landes-Code, genau so einstellen, dass nur in dem Land, in dem er sein Gerät verkauft, auch genau der Region-Code abspielbar ist. Damit eben nicht sogenannte Grau-Importe oder direkt importierte DVDs da abgespielt werden können. Das heißt, dass die Verschlüsselung insofern etwas damit zu tun hat. Und das, was diese Filminustrie so sehr aufregt und weswegen dieser ganze Prozess läuft, ist, es gab ein paar Computerfreaks in Norwegen und in anderen Ländern. Und so Stück für Stück wurde zusammengetragen, wie diese Verschlüsselung funktioniert und entsprechend auch, wie man die Entschlüsselung machen kann, ohne irgendwelche absurden Lizenzverträge unterzeichnen zu müssen. Und das hat eben diese Motion Picture of America, die haben ganz schlechte Laune gekriegt, dann haben sie ihre ganz torren Anwältin gerufen und haben gesagt, jetzt verklagen wir mal das Internet. Und naja, das klingt jetzt erst mal so absurd, weil derjenige, der es herausgefunden hat, das war ein 14-jähriger Norweger, der hat das ursprünglich mal gepostet, dem konnten sie also juristisch nicht so schrecklich viel, weil erstens Norwegen das juristische Gesetz, auf das sie sich berufen, gar nicht hat. Und zum anderen, weil der Junge minderjährig ist und Schadensersatz, das kannst du bei dem auch vergessen. Also sie haben dann letztendlich diejenigen angefangen zu verklagen, die systematisch das verbreitet haben. Zum Beispiel eben die 2600, die eine sogenannte Link-Liste hat, das heißt eine Liste von lauter Sites, die ihnen diese Codes verbreiten. So, und was dabei herauskommen soll oder wird, im ersten Prozess hat die 2600 verloren, ist, dass eben das nicht mehr verbreitet werden darf. Weil die zwei Sachen sagen, erstens dieser Code, das ist ihr geistiges Eigentum, und zweitens berufen sie sich auf ein absurdes amerikanisches Gesetz, nach dem die Verbreitung von Informationen über die Beseitigung von Kopierschutzmechanismen verboten ist. Die vergleichen das damit, als wenn es eine Information wäre, wie man Schlösser öffnet oder wie man eben Wohnungstüren aufbricht. Und die sagen halt, man darf nicht Informationen verbreiten, wie man geistiges Eigentum klaut. Und das heißt, die Grundannahme ist immer noch geistiges Eigentum und dass man das überhaupt klauen kann.
Ja, das ist wahr. Aber es ist noch mal eine kleine Feinheit, es geht dabei natürlich nicht um den Code, also um den Programmcode von DCSS, sondern es geht um den im Moment halt den Schlüssel, wenn ich es richtig mitgekriegt habe.
Nein, es geht um beides. In diesem Fall ist es auch nicht voneinander getrennt, sondern es ist tatsächlich so, dass der DCSS ist eben ein Programm, das eben die komplette Entschlüsselung sowohl mit Nutzung des Schlüssels als auch des natürlich geheim gehaltenen Algorithmuses eben macht. Und ja, was lehrt uns das jetzt? Das lehrt uns jetzt, dass die Filmindustrie will gerade sozusagen Kontrolle über das Internet anüben und was dahinter steht, und das haben sie in diesem Prozess, ich war da eine Woche in New York, auch immer wieder versucht zu beweisen, ist, dass innerhalb kürzester Zeit ja das, was im Moment so Tauschbörsen wie Napster für MP3, sprich Musikdateien möglich machen, innerhalb kürzester Zeit, wenn die Bandbreite in den Haushalten verfügbar ist, auch für Filme sein kann, und dann würden eben, und das ist eine sehr emotionale Adressierung gewesen, dann würden die Hollywood-Filmproduktionsfirmen keine Filme mehr machen können, weil keiner mehr die sehen, und vor allem, bzw. keiner würden die mehr bezahlen, wenn man die frei übers Internet ausüben könnte, dann könnten sie die Künstler nicht mehr bezahlen, und dann würden sie alle sterben. Und das haben sie wirklich in einer emotionalen Art und Weise da adressiert, so von Dingen Hollywood, the American Culture, bla, bla, bla. Es ist halt auch so, dass die Amerikaner auf Hollywood einiges geben. Hey Tim, du kannst mir jederzeit ins Wort fallen tun. Ich bin nicht ins Wort fallen. Schade, aber dann lass...
Für DIR aus mal Gedanken pausen. Also ich meine, fassen wir zusammen, also habe ich das bei uns richtig verstanden, dass die auch auf Intellectual Property sozusagen setzen dabei, um diesen Prozess zu gewinnen?
Auf Patent.
Na, es geht um ein Gesetz, das heißt das Digital Millennium Copyright Act und das ist eine Erweiterung des bestehenden, ich hoffe ich übersetze das jetzt richtig, des sozusagen dort bestehenden Urheberrechtsgesetzes, um die, genau, um die Verbreitung von Informationen über den Kopierschutzmechanismen noch mal unter besonders schwere Strafe zu stellen. Aber letztendlich geht es in der Tat um...
Sagen die, das ist ihr Algorithmus und den darf man nicht reingenieren und umgehen?
Exakt. Sie sagen, sie haben viel Geld dafür ausgeben, dass sich irgendwelche klugen Menschen das ausgedacht haben.
Und jetzt kann ich irgendein 14-jähriger Norweger daherkommen und einfach mal behaupten, dass die alle nur Scheiße gemacht haben.
Genau, weil nämlich jeder, der so ein... Jeder, der ein DVD-Player im Moment bauen will, jedes Industrieunternehmen muss eben nicht nur die Lizenzbedingungen erfüllen, sondern auch 10.000 Dollar an Lizenzgebühren dieser MPIA zahlen.
Also von meiner Betrachtung her geht es darum, dass sie ein Recht nicht bestreiten können. Das geht nicht wegzunehmen. Ich nenne mich das kreative Recht am Baskelen mit eigenen Geräten. Solange das ein Einzelner tut, wissen Sie, Sie haben keine Chance, es zu verbieten. Aber wenn irgendwer auch nur wagt zu berichten, dass das passieren konnte, weil die einen derartige Grundfehler beim Bau des Gerätes gemacht haben und damit andere Leute bestrafen wollen, die dieses Wissen verbreiten, also das kann man sich nicht gefallen lassen.
Also man hatte den Eindruck, dass es auch eher hier dem tatsächlich ums Prinzip geht. Und deswegen machen wir auf diese Radiosendung. Es geht nämlich darum, dass sie sich darauf berufen, wo kämen wir denn dahin? Das war wirklich die wörtliche Argumentation, wenn jeder das machen würde, wenn jeder sich nicht mehr um geistiges Eigentum kümmern würde. Und das heißt...
Das setzt natürlich voraus, dass wir dieses geistige Eigentum anerkennen.
Es gibt ja auch hier in Deutschland Juristen, die auf diesen ganzen Dingen stehen und die sogar ihren Lebensunterhalt damit finanzieren. Ich habe keinen Zweifel, dass auch die, wenn Hollywood ihnen ein bisschen Geld rüberwirft, hier irgendwelchen absurden Aktionismus verbreiten werden.
Interessant ist ja die Sache überhaupt, die die Gegenseite hat, die Argumente. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben DCSS in erster Linie gemacht, um die Sachen unter einem anderen Betriebssystem. Wir wollten diese Worte mit Ahnung gar nicht in den Mund nehmen. Wir wollen auch für Linux oder BSD DVDs abspielen lassen können, was aber bisher nicht ging, weil das DVD-Konsortium dafür keine Lizenz für eine Software unter Linux erteilt hat. Wir haben diesen Schlüssel und diesen Algorithm nicht rausgerückt. Wir haben gesagt, okay, machen wir es halt selbst, weil wir haben das Recht darauf, wenn wir eine DVD kaufen, dann haben wir das Recht erworben, uns die auch angucken zu dürfen, und zwar unter einem Betriebssystem, wie wir Lust haben. Da gibt es einen Streit darüber, ob das so okay ist oder nicht. Und in Deutschland zum Beispiel, oder in Europa nach dem europäischen Recht, wäre es halt so, da gibt es halt so eine Formulierung, dass es erlaubt ist, irgendwie Sachen zu analysieren, und irgendwie um die Ideen und Grundlagen irgendwie rauszukriegen, die Sachen eben auseinander zu pflücken, irgendwie zu rekompilieren, dekompilieren, wie auch immer, und dementsprechend das umzumodifizieren und für den eigenen Bedarf sozusagen, also um eben einfach diese DVDs und Unterdienungsangucken zu können. Und hier in Europa, würde ich mal vermuten, wäre die Sache möglicherweise anders ausgegangen als in Amerika, weil die doch ein bisschen verspannter drauf sind, was sowas angeht. Da hat die Industrie auch noch eine ganz, ganz andere Macht als hier in Europa.
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist halt, ob diese Lizenzierungspolitik, die da ja ein bisschen durchschimmert, auch insofern, als das bei Videos ja beispielsweise auch Kopiermöglichkeiten für den Einzelnen sogar juristisch legitim eingeräumt waren. Und eben die DVD halt auch ein Lizensierungsschema letztendlich hat, wo keiner das Zeug abspielen kann, wenn er eben nicht diese Region-Code und sonstige Lizenzbedingungen halt erfüllt.
Hat da eigentlich in Deutschland mal jemand gegen geklagt? Also ich meine, es könnte ja so eblicherweise sogar sittenwidrig sein, dass ja so viel vorgeschrieben wird. Also ich meine, zum Beispiel kann ja ein Buchautor oder ein Verlag ja auch nicht vorschreiben, dass du dieses Buch, was du gerade gekauft hast, eben nicht auf dem Scheißhaus lesen darfst. Das kann ja keiner vorschreiben irgendwie. Das würde nicht anerkannt werden als Einschränkung.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Also ich meine, du hast doch selber vorhin gesagt, dass dieser sozusagen Deklarierung geistigen Eigentums und die Art und Weise, wie damit Geld verdient wird, dass das mit Kontrollrechten zu tun hat. Das heißt doch, ich habe vorhin in deinem...
Zumindestens, ja klar, Sanktionierungkontrolle. Wenn du das von Kenntnis erlangst, dann kannst du das sanktionieren.
Genau, da steht da drin, wenn ich zum Beispiel das Werk erworben habe, also nehmen wir mal an, ich habe eine CD von diesen fanatischen Vier erworben, dann habe ich damit noch lange keine Nutzungsrechte erworben. Nein, habe ich nicht, sondern die unterliegen nach wie vor deren Deklarierungen. Das heißt, ich bin nicht so sicher, ob die nicht sagen könnten, dass das nicht auf dem Scheißhaus gespielt werden darf. Wenn sie das dann eben als Verunglümpfung, als Klo, Spülmusik irgendwie ansehen würden oder so.
Gut, die Frage ist, ob sie das auch durchgesetzt bekommen.
Nein, das können sie aber nicht durchgesetzt haben.
Sie können es ja dreimal irgendwie vorschreiben, aber...
Ich stelle mir gerade einen Eulenspiegel vor und auf der Titelseite steht, die Benutzung dieser Zeitschrift in Amtsgebäuden ist untersagt.
Ja gut, wir können ja mal ganz kurz noch mal zu dieser eigentlichen Diskussion zurückkommen, wo wir jetzt wieder bei den Amseln dann...
Na, ich habe das A-Wort gesagt.
Also was bei diesem Prozess bei rauskommt, ist sozusagen, erstmal die DVD, die amerikanischen Hacker haben natürlich auch argumentiert, dass wenn man das Zeug kopieren will, also wenn man die Movies kopieren will, dann kann man viel einfacher rippen. Das heißt, es gibt sogenannte Ripper oder auch Speedripper, die benutzen einfach ganz normale, legitim hergestellte und lizenzierte DVD-Player. Was ist Rippen, Andi? Nach Rippen ist einfach sozusagen Witz kopieren, sagen wir mal.
Also wenn man einen Pullover hat und dann im Faden zieht, dann rippelt man auf.
Ja, gut, aber...
Ich dachte, Speedripper schaffen irgendwie zwölf Jungfrauen in einer Vollmundnacht oder so.
Also das heißt, die klauen einfach die Bilder von den normal lizenzierten Playern zu Dingsen. Aber es war eben klar und es ist auch klar und die Hollywood...
Vielleicht sollte man auch kurz darauf hinweisen, dass das eben nicht alles theoretisch möglich ist, sondern bereits praktisch geschieht. Also dieser DE-CSS Source Code, also das Programm, was sozusagen diesem CSS Verschlüsselungsschutz der DVD umgeht, das hat natürlich trotz dieser Einwände von der Musikindustrie seine Verbreitung gefunden. Auch wenn es jetzt nicht viele Server gibt, wo das in großen leuchtenden Buchstaben drauf steht, dass jetzt hier dieser Source Code ist, weil das ist halt derzeit etwas schwierig, ist das Ding einfach auf dem Netz. Also es ist de facto raus, genauso wie das mit Napster seiner Zeit auch war, als der Source Code rauskam, was halt ein paar Tage irgendwo auf dem Server, und dann haben sie alle irgendwie das Muffensausen bekommen, oh Gott, oh Gott, so eine böse Software darf man noch nicht auf die Welt lassen, aber da war sie halt schon auf der Welt und seitdem gibt es sie und sie wird es halt auch immer weiter geben, bzw. auch diese Idee, die damit verbunden ist, geht immer weiter. Es gibt ja dann auch noch andere interessante Software-Systeme, die sozusagen diese Copyright-Umgehung noch sehr viel einfacher machen als zum Beispiel Napster. Und dieses DECSS führt gerade derzeit dazu, dass man eben auch DVDs einfach einlegen kann, Laptop, zack, mit DVD-Laufwerk, Software gestartet, dann rödel das Ding ein paar Stunden drauf rum und danach hat man eine 4 bis 6 oder 8 GB große Datei und da ist dann einfach mal die DVD drin und zwar nicht mehr verschlüsselt und auf Festplatte und im Idealfall dann eben direkt von dort auch abspielbar, das heißt man muss hier auch keinen Rohling drin, man läuft einfach mit dem Laptop rum, wo halt einfach Filme auf der Festplatte sind.
Chaosradio 53, hier auf Fritz. Wir reden über geistiges Eigentum und über genau das würden wir auch ganz gerne mit euch Hörern reden. Und zwar unter folgender Rufnummer.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Podstar, Podstar 7097 110.
Ihr seid ja der Meinung, dass es überhaupt noch so was wie Urheberrecht geben soll. Und wenn ja, warum? Und wenn nein, warum nicht?
Ja, nicht nur der Meinung, es würde uns interessieren, Leute, die jetzt selber künstlerisch in irgendeiner Form produzieren oder sagen wir mal, deren Lebensverdienst im Wesentlichen auf geistiger Arbeit, also ob das jetzt objektiv so ist, sei mal dahingestellt, aber wer das Gefühl hat, dass seine Werke, die er schafft und mit der er sein Lebensunterhalt bestreitet, auf wesentlichen geistiger Aktivität, im Wesentlichen auf geistiger Aktivität basiert, würde es uns schon interessieren, inwieweit ihr eure, welche Rechte ihr geschützt sehen wollt und auf welche Art und Weise. In Bezug auf das Werk oder eben auch in Bezug auf die Idee oder die Methodik, die ihr habt, um diese Werke zu erzeugen.
Ja, und hier ist nochmal die Nummer.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Podstar, 70 97 110.
Ähm, wen nehmen wir denn?
Ach so, so schnell kann das gehen. Na, was ist denn das?
Also, ich würde mal sagen, jetzt aus der Sicht von einem Künstler, wenn er jetzt irgendwie Musik oder so macht, dass man dann einfach sagt, er ist für die Vermarktung selbst verantwortlich, und man deswegen als MP3 auf seine Webseite stellt und dann eben die mit Bannern zuklatscht und dann so ein Geld verdient. Weil man muss ja nicht Millionen mit verdienen, sondern will ja eben davon leben, ne?
Benutzt du das Netz, um dir Musik zu organisieren?
Ja, also ich benutze auch Napster und ich muss sagen, wer kann dir denn persönlich habiten, mit irgendjemanden irgendetwas auszutauschen? Wenn du jetzt so einen großen Spiel wie Napster, kann man sicher nicht unterbinden, wenn man irgendwie da irgendwelche scheiß Gesetze schafft, aber so einen kleinen wird es immer weiter geben. Das kann man einfach nicht unterbinden, die gehen es bloß dagegen vor, dagegen vor, weil es so eine Art große Defolge ist. Aber ich denke mal, wenn Napster verboten werden würde, würde es trotzdem noch irgendwelche Seiten geben, wo du dir MP3s runterlagen kannst. Und wenn jetzt zum Beispiel jeder dafür selbstverantwortlich wäre, dann könnte er auch sagen, müsste er sich nicht nach irgendwelchen Gesetzen richten oder zum Patentamt rennen oder wie ich ihn gerade, dann würde er einfach sagen, ich möchte sonst so viel dafür oder nicht. Und wenn er dann zulässt, dass es kopiert wird, dann ist er halt selbst daran schuld.
Also meinst du, in dem Moment, wo es veröffentlicht ist, gehört es auch jedem?
Das heißt, der Künstler muss also das Geld schon in der Tasche haben, bevor er was veröffentlicht?
Nein, das ist ja eben, dass er auf seine Selbstwerte steht, Jürgen Banner zu klatschen, weil dadurch verdient er auch Geld.
Okay, jemand anders nimmt das Packt auf seine Seite ohne Banner dann? Dann verdient er ja nichts dran, an den Bannern, weil keiner Lust hat, Jürgen Banner zu gucken.
Na die Frage ist, warum sollte er das tun, wenn er nichts dran verdient?
Die Frage ist, warum sollte ich für eine CD ein Lied gut finden, das nur 10 Mark bezahlt. Und ich denke mal, wenn man zum Beispiel einen Band von einer größeren Organisation oder so die Songs ins Netz stellt und ich sogar bereit bin, ein paar Fennish pro Song zu zahlen, dann habe ich kein Problem. Ich sehe nicht, dass ich 10 Mark für eine CD bezahle, wo ein Lied drauf ist, weil ich es gut finde. Ich nenne es lieber als Internet, statt ein Netzzentrum, der sich aus dem Internet also eine keringe Gebühr pro Lied finde ich schon abdrückend, weil sie können viel auf etwas verdienen, aber eben nicht in diesem großen Summen.
Kaufst du eigentlich überhaupt CDs?
Ja, ab und zu mal, eher selten. Aber meistens die Sachen, die ich mir aus dem Internet halte, die kriegt man nicht zu einem CD-Led. Das ist auch mal ziemlich praktisch.
Er hat auch das Hauptproblem im Moment aufmerksam gemacht, nämlich man kann einfach noch nicht das Geld senden. Da fehlt einfach noch diese, ich schicke jetzt mal dem Künstler ein paar Fennech oder eine Mark oder wie viel auch immer, dafür, dass ich das jetzt gerade cool finde.
Oder andersrum, die Einsicht der Plattenfirmen, dass sie ihre Preise doch ein bisschen überzogen haben.
Ich meine, es ist doch viel besser. Er hat doch gerade gesagt, ich finde es auch nämlich, weil in so einen Laden zu gehen, das kostet mich erstmal Zeit und dann irgendwie zu entscheiden, wer wie wo was ist. Das ist doch viel cooler, wenn ich das aufs Netz machen kann.
Wie ich schon vorhin bemerkte, die CD hast du schneller bestellt, als dir das Lied runtergeladen, auf jeden Fall. Du kannst es genauso im Netz bestellen, wie du im Netz jetzt runterladen kannst.
Also dann zeige ich dir mal, wie das schneller geht, Tim. Ich glaube, da machen wir mal ein Wettbewerb.
Wie, du kaufst schneller eine CD im Laden, als ich sie mir im Netz bestellt habe?
Nein, ich glaube, dass ich mir eher die Bits schneller aus dem Netz ziehe, als MP3, als mir eine CD zu bestellen. Bestellen ist eine Sache, aber bis sie dabei ist...
Ja klar, sie sehen, wo ich dir mit zehn Tasten eingeben habe und mit fünf Mausklicks habe ich das Ding bestellt.
Ja, bestellt, aber da ist es noch nicht da. Ich habe mit derselben Anzahl von Mausklick und einer halben Stunde warten.
Ja, du gehörst aber auch zu den Leuten, denen so ein Modell sowieso nicht näher zu bringen wäre. Die wird es auch immer geben, das ist vollkommen klar. Es gibt halt Sozialschmarotzer...
Moment, Moment, Moment, ich bin ja durchaus bereit, den Künstlern, ne, das lasse ich auch nicht auf mir sitzen. Also ich bin durchaus bereit, Leuten die coole Sachen machen, dafür zu zahlen. So bloß ich muss nicht unbedingt deren CDs besitzen, weil CDs finde ich auch ganz schön unpraktisch. Ich bin sehr viel unterwegs.
Na gut, viele Leute bringen ja einer CD auch eine bestimmte Wertschätzung entgegen. Da haben sie irgendwie was Persönliches, da ist noch ein Bucket dabei. Und sie müssen sich eben nicht einen Computer und einen CD-Brenner besorgen und Rohlinge kaufen und vorrätig haben und tralala, um das in jedem beliebigen CD-Player reinstecken zu können. Ist ja in Ordnung. Ich meine, ich finde nichts dagegen, CDs zu verkaufen. Aber ich denke eben auch, dass in dem Moment, und da sind wir bei einer der Kernaussagen, wenn man etwas veröffentlicht, egal über welcher Gesetzeslage, dann ist es halt öffentlich, dann steht es im öffentlichen Raum. Und damit ist es eigentlich auch schon Bestandteil des Gesamtkulturguts. Ich meine, für populäre Titel ist das sicherlich unbestreitbar so. Bei Leuten, die Nischenmärkte besitzen, ist es auch so.
Als erstes wollte ich mal sagen, wenn etwas wirklich gut ist, dann bin ich auch dafür bereit, also Geld dafür zu bezahlen. Also ich gehe gerne CDs kaufen, obwohl ich, na ich bin auch gerne im Laden, aber eigentlich finde ich CDs natürlich ziemlich unpraktisch. Also ich habe mir auch einen Banner gekauft und ich bin zurzeit dabei, also alles auf Festplatte und dann auf CD und wenn ich dann mal zum Freund gehe, dann kann ich so 120 Lieder mitnehmen. Das finde ich also extrem praktisch.
Also du brennst dir den MP3-CD meinst du?
Na klar, ich meine, das reicht mir vollkommen. So 192 Kilobit habe ich rausgefunden, mehr kann ich sowieso nicht hören und dann bin ich immer gut dabei. Und das zweite ist, ich wollte auch sagen, das mit dem Buchdruck, was ihr so angesprochen habt, man kann ja nicht bestreiten, dass das, sagen wir mal, unsere Gesellschaft sehr viel weitergebracht hat. Und das sehe ich jetzt genauso. Es ist einfach wahrscheinlich auch für die Gesellschaft irgendwie günstiger, also jetzt von der Entwicklung her, dass man sich einfach, sagen wir mal, wissen, einfach zu kopieren kann und damit auch was anfangen kann. Ich meine, Geld ist ja sowas wie, für jedenfalls für mich sowas wie eine Krücke. Also eigentlich ist Geld gar nicht nötig. Zum Beispiel die meisten Leute sagen, ich möchte so viel Geld haben, dass ich nicht mehr drüber nachdenken muss. Aber das zeigt mir, dass Geld eigentlich nicht in der Natur des Menschen liegt. Und natürlich, der Künstler muss irgendwie auch überleben können. Aber eigentlich geht es ja darum, eher so ein Werk zu schaffen.
Wie siehst du das zum Beispiel bei T-Shirts? Also angenommen, jemand würde jetzt ein tolles T-Shirt machen und das auch verkaufen. Was ist dann mit diesem T-Shirt? Verhältst du das dann genauso wie Musik?
Fabian, warte mal mit der Antwort. Wir müssen kurz Nachrichten machen. Bleib einfach dran, ja? Okay, bis gleich. Entschuldigt, Jungs, aber nicht. Ja, jetzt ja was zu anführen. Mach ich doch gerade. Es ist nämlich 23.32 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Nachts um 10 Grad, tagswechselhaft mit Schauern bis 24 Grad. Die Meldung mit Gerald Katter-Henrich.
Ja, zu ist besser. Werner Wallert und fünf andere freigelassene Geiseln sollen heute in Libyen eintreffen. Dort werden sie mit Staatschef Gaddafi sprechen. Libyen hatte vermittelt und Millionensummen als Lösegeld gezahlt. Wallert wird nach Planung des Auswärtigen Amtes noch am gleichen Tage in Deutschland zurückerwartet. Die Vorwürfe gegen Brandenburger Polizisten beschäftigen den Innenausschuss des Landtages. Vorsitzender Schulze kündigte an, er wolle so schnell als möglich eine Sondersitzung einberufen. Nach ausländerfeindlichen Angriffen in Teltow und Rathenow hatten die Opfer Polizeibeamten vorgeworfen, nicht ausreichend eingeschritten zu sein. Die Deutsche Angestelltengewerkschaft lehnt eine Änderung des Ladenschlussgesetzes ab. Sie reagierte damit auf den Vorstoß der Bundesländer, die für Werktage erweiterte Öffnungszeiten bis 22 Uhr und für den Samstag bis 20 Uhr anstreben. An Sonn- und Feiertagen sollen die Läden in der Regel geschlossen bleiben. Ein Teil der Berliner U-Bahnen und alle S-Bahnen sollen in einigen Jahren auch Werktags die ganze Nacht hindurchfahren, das bestätigten Sprecher von BVG und S-Bahn. Vorher müssen allerdings noch die technischen Voraussetzungen geschaffen werden.
72 Stunden in der Wildnis, ohne Handy, ohne Freunde, ohne Kino, ohne Supermarkt, ohne Musik, ohne Mami, ohne alles. Dafür mit Abenteuer Survival Action.
Alles musst du dir selber machen.
Schlafplatz besorgen, Hütte bauen, Essen sammeln, Feuer machen ohne Streichholz.
Bewehr zum Fritz-Waldländer.
Fritz und alle Hörer sind bei dir, im Radio und im Internet.
Vom 30. September bis 3. Oktober.
Bewirb dich jetzt.
Zeig, dass du es schaffst.
Gewinn den Überraschungspreis.
0331 70 97 110. Alle gewinnen.
Oder keiner.
Die Fritz-Waldländer. 72 Stunden Abenteuer. Ohne alles.
Hier ist das Chaosradio 53 auf Fritz. Wir reden über Urheberrecht und Fabian ist immer noch am Telefon.
Ja, bin ich.
Du hast dir jetzt eine tolle Antwort überlegt, ne? Oder Tim, stell nochmal die Frage.
Was war denn nochmal die Frage?
Fabian, was war nochmal die Frage?
Wie ich das dann mit einem T-Shirt finden soll. Ja, die Sache ist, für ein gutes T-Shirt würde ich natürlich Geld ausgeben. Jetzt allerdings die Idee, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, das T-Shirt sehe ich im Laden und ich finde das ganz toll. Ich könnte das aber jetzt zu Hause mit einem Grafikprogramm und einem Drucker einfach raus, dann würde ich das quasi mir überlassen, ob ich das dann mache oder nicht.
Ja, also du würdest dir auch das Recht herausnehmen, das Motiv sozusagen selber auf T-Shirts zu drucken und dann auch weiter zu verkaufen? Wenn es frei ist, ist ja zum Beispiel auch bei GNU Software so. Du verkaufst sie zwar nicht im einigen Sinne, wie man etwas verkauft, aber du darfst halt für das Ausliefern sozusagen Geld nehmen, was halt auch bei T-Shirts der Fall ist.
Na ja, weil ich meine...
Also siehst du das auch da genauso oder würdest du da noch einen Unterschied machen?
Also für mich persönlich würde ich es natürlich machen, aber wenn ich das verkaufen würde, dann würde ich das höchstens mit Hinweis auf den anderen machen würden, weil das quasi seine Idee ist. Ich möchte mich nicht mit Fremden-Schweden schmücken, sage ich mal. Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwie vielleicht draufschreiben würde, wenn das jetzt, sagen wir mal, irgendwie quasi dann allgemein anerkannt wäre, ich mache ein Verweis darauf, dass es eine andere vielleicht irgendwie, dass das seine Idee ist und dass ich die irgendwie ganz toll fand und dann würde ich das dann vielleicht machen.
Davon kann sich der andere aber auch noch nichts kaufen.
Oh doch. Ich meine, das ist ja die Frage, ob das jetzt sozusagen eigentlich sein Recht ist, dass er auch an deiner Arbeit, sozusagen an deinem Werk, die sozusagen auf der Idee des anderen beruht oder auch auf dem Werk des anderen beruht, dass du damit genauso Geld machen kannst wie er auch. Du bist ein bisschen am Zögern. Ich meine, ich denke, das ist genau der Punkt, wo man nämlich auch selber so ein bisschen ins Zögern kommt, weil das ist halt gerade anders. Da gibt es halt das Urheberrecht und das sagt irgendwie, der Urheber darf bestimmen, auf welche Art und Weise es verbreitet wird. Und auch wenn viele Leute was freigeben, geben sie es nicht selten, nur unter der Bedingung frei, dass es eben, dass damit nicht Geld verdient wird, sondern dass nur private Nutzung erlaubt.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das hat was mit schlechtem Gewissen zu tun, weil man denkt, man bringt da jemand um etwas. Na ja, das fängt ja...
Guck mal, so ein T-Shirt, das muss ja auch gemacht werden. Und ich finde ein gutes T-Shirt-Entwurf, meinetwegen sitzt du eine Woche, das ist irgendwie ein Betrag X, und den hättest du auch gerne wieder rein, weil du willst nämlich nächste Woche am nächsten T-Shirt arbeiten und du brauchst dafür was zu fressen.
Ja, logisch, klar, aber die bittere Realität ist doch, dass die Welt schon so ein Stück weit funktioniert. Das heißt, entweder du schaffst es, die T-Shirt zu verkaufen, und ob du tolle T-Shirts, also beziehungsweise ob du einen guten Umsatz hast, liegt ja heute oftmals nicht daran, ob du ein tolles Motiv hast, sondern ob dein Laden irgendwie, weißt du, ob überhaupt Leute vorbeikommen und so fort.
Also wie gutes Verkaufen.
Ja, der Akt des Verkaufens ist halt leider auch ein Wert.
Ja, ich denke, das ist sogar der eigentliche Wert. Oder? Sind schon das ähnlich?
Also das Problem ist ja eigentlich, dass der, dass der, sagen wir mal, mit der Idee eigentlich, dass er irgendwie was davon abhaben sollte oder soll oder was weiß ich.
Also Lizenzgebühren.
Ja, und die Sache ist nur, sagen wir mal, wenn das so ein reicher Multimillionär ist, dann braucht er quasi nichts mehr davon, sage ich mal. Der soll quasi nur, sagen wir mal, die Ehre bekommen. Und sagen wir mal, dass man auch nicht das Leben führen kann.
Wenn es kein Multimillionär ist?
Wie bitte?
Künstler sind...
Ja, dann ist ja gerade die Frage, wie kann man das realisieren, dass er quasi sein Geld kriegt. Also, wie bei euch beschrieben, so ein Button, da drückt man drauf, dann kriegt er einen Markt. Also das würde ich zum Schuss sehr gut finden.
Macht sich halt bei T-Shirts nicht so gut.
Wieso? Es kommt schon noch.
Ich kann es sagen. Er verkauft ja T-Shirts zwar auch, aber du stellst halt irgendwie noch einen Button daneben und hier gibt es irgendwie einen Markt für denjenigen, der das sozusagen gemacht hat. Und wenn du den auch noch beglücken willst, kannst du da drauf drücken. Kannst du auch selber machen. Du kannst ja sozusagen es verkaufen und dann irgendwie von dir aus sozusagen dafür, dass du es jetzt verkauft hast, auf den Button drücken.
Gut, es ist aber das Problem, weil irgendwie ein Großteil unseres Lebens besteht irgendwie aus Sachen, die irgendwie das Urheberrecht betreffen. Und wenn du für alles irgendwie so einen Button drücken müsstest irgendwie...
Nein, nein, ich rede nicht von Button drücken müssen. Ich rede von Button drücken dürfen.
Okay, aber überleg mal, dass irgendwie pro Tag sind irgendwie 20.000 Buttons, die du drücken könntest. Und davon drückst du aber nur von zwei. Das heißt, dass irgendwie über 19.000 irgendwie nicht gedrückt werden.
Ja, wenn ich mir irgendwie bestimmte Leute angucke, dann habe ich auch den Eindruck, die haben auch genug Kohle. Da gebe ich das Geld irgendwie lieber, keine Ahnung, jemand der noch nicht so viel Kohle hat.
Ja, aber ich rede jetzt auch von einer, sagen wir mal, von einer Einzelperson, die irgendwie ein T-Shirt macht. Und es gibt halt zwei Sachen. Es gibt irgendwie die Dienstleistung des Verkaufens, mit dem er versucht, das Geld wieder hereinzubekommen und irgendwie einen gewissen Lohn für die Arbeit, die er in das entwickeln des T-Shirts gemacht hat. Dann könnte man auch annehmen, dass es im Wesentlichen dafür entwickelt hat, um es zu verkaufen. Jetzt verkauft es jemand anders auch, vielleicht ein bisschen effektiver, das mindert halt seine Beiträge, aber trotzdem kann er nicht wirklich für sich in Anspruch nehmen, dass das jetzt sein Werk ist, weil in der Regel eben auch diese Idee, die zu diesem Werk geführt hat, letzten Endes auf den Ideen anderer beruht.
Vielleicht nochmal was aus der Computerei. Es gibt sowas wie Freeware, da kann man sich das Programm quasi runterladen. Und wenn man das dann richtig gut findet, dann steht auch drauf, ich möchte nichts dafür haben, aber wenn es euch wirklich gefällt, dann könnt ihr mir zum Beispiel einen angemessenen Geldbetrag schicken. Oder vielleicht, ich habe ein Programm, da muss man nur eine Postkarte schicken. Da sagt er, ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr mir eine Postkarte schickt, aus eurer Stadt oder was. Dann könnt ihr mir so was draufschreiben und die hänge ich mir alle ins Zimmer. Sowas finde ich zum Beispiel richtig klasse und sowas mache ich dann auch.
Das ist auch eine schöne Idee, aber davon kann er halt nicht wirklich viel mehr leben.
Na gut, ich meine, Shareware funktioniert. Zumindest in den USA funktioniert das ganz gut. Ich glaube, es gibt wirklich viele Autoren, die davon ihren Lebensunterhalt bestreiten, die nicht selten alleine programmieren und das machen. Also du meintest Shareware, du meintest nicht Freeware.
Die bestehen ja quasi darauf.
Okay, mittlerweile ist es meistens so, dass Shareware dann irgendwann verhindert, dass wenn du nicht bezahlt hast, dass du das Programm weiter benutzen kannst. Das war aber bei der ursprünglichen Idee von Shareware nicht der Fall. Shareware war früher halt generell voll funktional und alles andere nannte man eigentlich später Crippleware. Mittlerweile ist das allerdings verwischend.
Die Frage ist, gibt es irgendwelche Bereiche, wo ein Kontrollanspruch wirklich legitim ist? Also wo tatsächlich der Autor das Recht haben soll zu sagen, wenn du mir nicht genug Geld zahlst, dann nicht.
Du solltest ja nicht haben.
Okay, finde ich nämlich auch.
Fabian, danke. So, Tilman, nach Abend.
Guten Abend.
Kann ich noch mal zu eurem Grundpunkt oder Anfangspunkt zurückkommen?
Gerne.
Ohne dieses A-Wort zu benutzen.
Das A-Wort, das A-Wort.
Wobei eben sagte der Fabian, sehr schön, dass das Problem mit diesen mit fremden Federn schmücken.
Trink deinen Kakao und gib mir noch eine Schokolade.
Die Amsel verschwunden. Okay, dann geh doch mal auf unseren Grundthema ein.
Ja, also ihr sagtet irgendwie was von, man müsste den Pythagoras dann auch lizenzieren oder so was.
Na ja, das sagt Andi.
Das sagt eigentlich keiner von uns. Das war ein Beispiel für die Abstrusität der Grundideen.
Welche rote Idee?
Der Grundidee, Lizenzgeführen für ein...
Nicht das Werk, sondern der Idee.
Der Idee für eine Idee, Lizenzgebühren zu...
Aber das ist so nicht... Patente sind ausdrücklich nur für technische Erfindungen und nicht für mathematische Theorien, Pläne und Verfahren.
Und was ist mit der Patentierung von Software?
Na, das ist ja nun eine technische Erfindung für Verfahren oder...
Ja, aber da ist der Übergang ja nun schon ein bisschen fließend, oder?
Nee, also wenn du irgendwie eine mathematische Theorie aufstellst, weiß ich, a² plus b² gleich c², dann kannst du das herleiten aus dieser Wissenschaft.
Gibt es aber ein...
Es gibt auch ein schönes Beispiel. Kennst du dieses Problem mit amazon.com?
Wo ist das Problem mit denen?
Die haben sich ein Geschäftsmodell sozusagen patentieren lassen. In den USA kann man sich nämlich auch sowas patentieren lassen, also ein bestimmtes Verfahren, bestimmte Dinge abzuwickeln. Und was sie sich haben patentieren lassen, ist die sogenannte One-Click-Bestellung. Das ist im Prinzip eigentlich überhaupt keine großartige Erfindung. Das ist halt nur das Benutzen von Cookies, die seinerzeit Netscape erfunden hat, zum Abspeichern der Benutzerkennung auf dem eigenen Rechner. Und wenn man halt das nächste Mal hingeht, weiß das System sofort, um wen es sich handelt. Und du brauchst halt nur noch auf einen Button draufklicken, und dann hast du irgendwie deinen Einkaufswagen. Du sagst, okay, an meine Default-Adresse, dann kriegst du es zugeschickt. Das war natürlich eine verdammt gute Idee. Und eigentlich, jeder der Cookies vorher kannte, wusste, dass die natürlich genau für solche Anwendungen mal erfunden wurden. Trotzdem hat amazon.com ein Patent darauf erhalten und verbietet nun per Gerichtsbescheiden, anderen Systemen exakt dieselbe Methode anzuwenden.
Hatten diese Systeme denn schon, bevor Amazon das gemacht hatte, auch diese One-Click-Methode?
Es gab zumindest niemanden, der es genau so nannte. Es gab zumindest niemanden, der es vor Ihnen patentiert hat.
Das ist eben wohl deren Fehler gewesen. Na Moment, das ist...
Findest du denn das legitim?
Dieses Prinzip, wer zuerst kommt, mal zuerst, ist nicht so in Ordnung. Wenn Leute unabhängig voneinander eine Erfindung haben, ja, sollen sie die haben und patentieren lassen.
Ja Moment, aber die Frage ist ja, muss ich jetzt mal als Gegenfall, nehmen wir mal an, ich erfinde etwas und ich will das ganz bestimmt nicht patentieren, sondern ich will, dass es weiterentwickelt wird. Ich bin mir bewusst, dass es nur ein Zwischenschritt in der Evolution ist. Jetzt erfindet aber ein anderer das auch oder findet das, weil ich das ins Netz gestellt habe und rennt damit zum Patentanwalt und sagt, das ist seins. Jetzt kannst du natürlich sagen, wer zuerst mal zuerst, selber schuld, wenn es blöd war, zum Patentanwalt zu gehen. Aber ich hatte ja noch die Idee, und da bin ich vielleicht ein bisschen naiv gewesen, dass es noch so etwas wie den öffentlichen Raum gibt. Ja, aber das Netz ist ja eigentlich im Moment, wenn du dir die Newsnet-Forun oder so etwas anguckst, da ist doch... Oh, da sehe ich gerade Stürmrunzeln.
Du kannst ja natürlich auch die Methode, russische Marinesoldaten aus U-Booten zu befreien, patentieren lassen. Und wenn die Russen das nächste Mal ein Problem haben, müssen sie erst mal Lizenzgebühren abdrücken. Das ist alles beliebig verschlimmerbar. Es gibt auch gute Beispiele derzeit im Pharma-Bereich. Die Jungs fahren gerade durch die Weltgeschichte und gucken sich Methoden an wie alte Völker. Es gibt da ein schönes Beispiel aus Indien, wie die bestimmte Kräuter angewendet haben, um bestimmte Krankheiten zu verhindern. Dann schnappen sie sich irgendwie diese Methode des Anrührens und gehen dann so weit, das eben patentieren zu lassen und dann am Schluss auch die Leute, die es die ganze Zeit benutzt haben, dafür zu Kasse zu binden.
Also ich denke auch, dass das Patentrecht in Deutschland im Vergleich zu Amerika sehr viel entspannter ist.
Heilverfahren ja, aber wenn es um den Einsatz konkreter Substanzen geht, dann nennt man das irgendwann Medikament und dann ist das irgendwie ein Produkt. Und ich meine, die Mittel werden bereits gefunden, um genau so etwas patentieren zu lassen. Und wo wir jetzt nun mal schon mal generell diese Gesetzgebungen in der Welt haben, die werden derzeit eher noch schlimmer als lockerer.
Es gibt aber kein Weltgesetz. Jeder Staat, jedes Land hat ja seine eigenen Gesetze, wie die Europäische Union oder andere Unionen.
Jaja, das ist richtig.
Das ist das Problem auch irgendwo, dass auf der Welt eben überall andere Gesetze existieren. Dadurch können selbstverständlich auch nicht in Norwegen den kleinen Jungen festnehmen oder so.
Ja, das sind halt die Inseln, die wir derzeit noch haben, die überhaupt noch ein bisschen Bewegung in das System bringen. Aber wir reden ja im Prinzip genau von diesen Trends. Und es wird derzeit in der Politik auch kräftig diskutiert, was denn die richtige Vorgehensweise wäre. Brauchen wir Software-Patente? Da gibt es hier ein paar Firmen, die schreien halt laut auf. Voran natürlich IBM, weil die haben am meisten. Weil nämlich Patente heutzutage vor allem auch ein Mittel sind, um Konkurrenten von vornherein aus bestimmten Geschäftsbereichen rauszuhalten. Weil sie sagen, so viele Patente wie ihr jetzt von uns kaufen müsst, um das wirklich auch weiterentwickeln zu können. Obwohl das vielleicht eine tolle Sache ist, Medikament gegen AIDS oder so. Aber da kommt halt irgendjemand und sagt, das ist aber mein Patent und so. Dann kannst du einfach mal backen. Da mach ich jetzt Kohle mit und du nicht. Aber dann ist es eben nicht mehr gut für die Gemeinschaft. Weil das kann nicht gut sein, wenn wir irgendwie alles nur auf eine einzelne Person oder Firma in diesem Fall akkumulieren.
Ja, das ist auch, glaube ich, so ein Problem, dass eben dann für eine gewisse Zeit jemand dieses Monopol hat. Das ist ja dieser Grundgedanke, dass einer dann für einen gewissen Zeitraum sich das Monopol kaufen kann und das dann auch immer wieder verlängern lassen kann. Wobei das dann auch, glaube ich, sobald es vielleicht immer teurer wird. Also es muss dann sozusagen davon abhängen, wie erfolgreich dann dieses Patent wird.
Aber findest du das gut, dass es das gibt so mit den Patenten?
Also es gibt davor Nachteile. Da muss man genau abwiegen.
Was siehst du denn als Vorteil?
Dass Leute ihr literarisches oder geistiges Eigentum wahren können. Dass nicht irgendwelche andere Leute dann sagen können, ja das habe ich hier gemacht und jetzt bezahlt mir da für dieses Produkt irgendwie Geld.
Aber er macht das dann?
Ja, aber er macht das dann.
Und das darf der auch?
Das darf er dann nicht, wenn das patentiert wurde.
Aber wenn er es patentiert hat, darf er es ja machen. Also es redet jetzt von demjenigen, der das Patent hat. Was findest du legitim, dass er das tun darf?
Ja, um dann eben seine Idee oder seine tolle Erfindung zu schützen vor Nachahmern, die dann dafür Geld verlangen und das dann einfach missbrauchen. Das ist auch neben der Gefahr, wenn man jetzt überhaupt keine Urheberrechte mehr hat. Wenn jemand malt ein tolles Bild, ein alter Van Gogh, der noch niemand kennt und irgendwie man entdeckt ihn und ja, sagt hier, ich hab das hier gestern gemalt, findet es nicht alle toll und sowas. Also eine Urheberrechte und sowas sollte, glaube ich, noch gewahrt werden. Dass es natürlich nicht mehr überprüfbar ist durch das Internet, weil es ja nun absolut zentral ist, ist klar.
Also wir wollen vor allem zwei Sachen auseinanderhalten. Vielleicht mal kurz noch mal alles nachgeschoben. Wir wollen unterscheiden zwischen den Werken, die man tut, also den Dingen, die man irgendwie schafft, und den Ideen, die ihnen zugrunde liegen. Unsere Position ist hier im Wesentlichen, dass man eben Ideen gar nicht seine Eigentum nennen kann. Also dass es so etwas wie geistiges Eigentum de facto nicht gibt. Weil dann müsste es so etwas geben wie eine eigene Idee. Und wir denken nicht, dass es so etwas gibt.
Überhaupt nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so etwas gibt. Na was wäre denn deiner Meinung nach eine eigene Idee?
Na wenn irgendjemand ein kreatives Muster oder eine Form entdeckt oder erfindet.
Er erfindet sie ja nicht.
Darf ich mal dazwischen?
Ja bitte, Wau. Weiß ich jetzt hier das Fritz-Logo. Wer käme auf diese Idee, so ein F jetzt plastisch und als Person mit einem Auge darzustellen?
Das ist ein Werk.
Microsoft Encarta ist auch ein Werk und da sind ein Haufen Ideen drin. Und was mich bei dem Ding fürchterlich stört, ist, dass beispielsweise in jedem Land, in jeder länderspezifischen Ausgabe ein anderer Mensch das Telefon erfunden hat. Das ist ein Werk, was ich nicht wirklich will. Was ich gerne haben möchte, sind offene Werke, wo das Wissen der Welt drin ist, wo diejenigen, die das zusammentragen, auch benannt werden. Eine Art GPL-Version vom Wissen.
Meinst du, das ist die Wissenschaft?
Ja, von allgemeinem Wissen, von allgemeinem Wissen, wo jetzt nicht irgendwer hergeht und sagt irgendwie, du bist eine Leihbibliothek und darfst zwar öffentlich Bücher ausleihen, aber Fernleihe mit anderen Leihbibliotheken ist dir verboten, weil das ist eine andere Geschäftsperson. Und derartige Dinge laufen heute.
Ich kann dir nicht ganz folgen. Also ich glaube, ich bin auch nicht da ein Einziger, oder?
Kann das einer übersetzen? Nein, wir bringen mal wieder zwei Sachen zusammen, glaube ich, die jetzt nicht unbedingt zusammen genannt werden müssten. Also die Idee, eine Idee, wir zweifeln an, dass es so etwas gibt wie eine eigene Idee. Und weil, zwangsläufig deine Ideen auf den Ideen und dem von dir akkumulierten Wissen basieren und damit eben auf den geistigen Tätigkeiten aller anderen Menschen. Du kannst nicht irgendwie für eine Maschine ein neues Verfahren erarbeiten, hätte nicht jemand diese Maschine als solche zunächst einmal in irgendeiner Form erfunden. Ja, Fraunhofer könnte irgendwie sein psychoakustisches Modell im Audiolayer 3 von MPEG nicht ansiedeln, wenn es eben dieses MPEG-Framework nicht gäbe, worin das Ganze läuft.
Also wobei bei Patenten die Diener in erster Linie dazu, irgendwelche Investitionen von Firmen zu schützen. Das heißt also, wenn die jetzt irgendwie eine Milliarde Mark für irgendwelche Forschungssachen ausgegeben haben, wie zum Beispiel Fraunhofer, von wem das Geld kommt, das ist noch ein anderes Thema, aber Fraunhofer hat halt irgendwie ganz viel Geld dafür ausgegeben.
Nein, das ist überhaupt kein anderes Thema, das waren nur die Steuergelder.
Ja, gut, aber trotzdem hat Fraunhofer dafür erstmal irgendwie einen Betrag X aufgewendet, um dieses Modell zu erschaffen.
In den USA sind die Ergebnisse von Forschungen mit Steuergeldern frei.
Ja, das ist aber eine ganz andere Diskussion.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, aber du würdest doch zustimmen, dass wenn eine Universität Gelder bekommt für öffentliche Forschung, dass dann auch das, was sie erforschen, die Ergebnisse, sollten auch der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich sein, oder?
Ja, das denke ich auch ganz dafür, dass beispielsweise dieses menschliche Genom, dieses Buch sozusagen eben veröffentlicht wird im Internet, meinetwegen.
Oh ja, und vor allem niemand gehört.
Ganz genau, niemand gehört. Ich finde es auch pervers, dass irgendwelche menschlichen Gene patentiert werden. Jetzt müssen wir irgendwie alle zum Patent trennen und unser Gen patentieren lassen, damit uns niemand klont, oder wie?
Also du findest es auch zweifelhaft, was gerade passiert mit den Ideen?
Also ich denke, der wirkliche Punkt der Diskussion hier ist irgendwie der Weg, der Schritt zwischen einer Idee und einem Werk, das was dazwischen ist, was irgendwo dann beim Patentrecht ankommt. Das heißt also, was deutlich mehr ist als wegen die Buchidee vom durchgeknallten Busfahrer oder so. Es ist aber noch nicht das komplette 400-seitige Buch, sondern vielleicht irgendwas dahinten.
Den Busfahrer hat ja auch dann irgendjemand erfunden. Aber den Bus und den Motor und so.
Ich will unbedingt den Typen besprechen, der irgendwie Berliner Busfahrer erfunden hat.
666 anrufen. Tillmann, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ich habe Berlin erfunden.
Fragen wir mal, vielleicht lebt er ja in Süddeutschland. Orkun, bist du noch da? Hallo. Hallo.
Ich bin jetzt auf Sendung.
Du bist auf Sendung.
Klasse, da kann ich ja zu meinem Thema kommen. Und zwar, ich habe den Anfang eurer Sendung nicht mitbekommen. Allerdings, ich habe...
Dir auch nicht.
dann zugehört und habe mir noch die Seite, die Webseite durchgelesen. Und zwar wird hier die Frage gestellt, wie finanzieren wir in Zukunft die Kunst? Bin ich jetzt richtig?
Ja, du bist ganz richtig. Sag mal, wie?
Und zwar, jetzt ist hier Folgendes. Es besteht, es steht im Raum ein Dilemma. Und zwar einerseits Freiheit der Bytes, keine Filter für MP3s, bezüglich einer etwas älteren Chaosradiosendung, wo ja getestet wurde, dass das technisch machbar ist und so weiter und sofort. Und dann gibt es noch die Industrie, die Juristen und so weiter. Die schreien ja alle auf und Pipapo und Urheberrecht und das geht ja nicht und bla bla bla. Jetzt gibt es ja vielleicht folgende Lösung. Und zwar, die Künstler vereinigen sich alle. Und die Industrie, die mächtig Kohle kassiert an diesem ganzen Machwerk, muss aufgrund des Drängens der Künstler einen Topf kreieren. In diesem Topf muss die Industrie einzahlen, weil CDs und Videos und DVDs etc. werden die nächsten 50 Jahre immer noch verkauft. Vielleicht zwar nicht immer, aber es ist ja auch ein Problem, dass die Künstler nicht so ultra, sondern verkauft werden. Dann gibt es im Internet, in Shops oder irgendwo eine Fame-List, wo die ganzen User, die das öffentlich nicht hören, dann Credits vergeben können. Die sagen, der war gut, der war gut etc. Auf gut Deutsch ein Ranking entsteht. Und der, der am Ranking oben ist, bekommt so und so viel Geld aus diesem Topf und so weiter und so fort. Und ich bin mir sicher, das wird auch viele daran, diese etwas freiere Form des Finanzieren des Guten, sage ich jetzt mal, wird viele dann nicht davon abhalten, jetzt zum Beispiel keine CD zu kaufen. Sondern vielleicht werden sie gerade deshalb sich denken, Mensch, das ist jetzt zum Beispiel eine Motivation.
In Deutschland heißt sowas GEMA.
Gibt es schon. Und die Charts werden halt nicht im Internet gebildet, sondern von...
Von den Radiostationen und die wieder durch die Hörer, die irgendwie Werbe und lalala...
Ja, zum Beispiel. Und das dann auf eine andere Weise hochziehen zum Beispiel, aufziehen oder aufmachen.
Naja, was sollte dann der grundlegende Unterschied zu dem anderen Modell sein? Da hast du immer noch das Problem, dass du eine ganze Menge Leute anstellen musst, um diesen Vorgang zu verwalten. Mit anderen Worten, du schaffst ja eine Bürokratie. Und wie effektiv die ist, sehen wir nicht nur an dem Beispiel GEMA. Also viele Leute, die sozusagen auch ein Anrecht haben, deren Musik vielleicht auch in dieser Chaosradio-Sendung gerade tatsächlich gespielt wird, werden von dieser GEMA niemals Geld sehen. Allein schon, weil sie keine korrekten Playlists bekommen und sich eigentlich nur Moderatoren, die irgendwie Charts auflegen, Playlist generieren. Oder, Olga, wie machst du das?
Wann? Das ist abhängig. Im Moment schreibe ich nichts mit. Wenn ich die Platten selber auswähle, die ich spiele, dann schreibe ich auf, was es ist. Und das ist abends ja meistens der Fall. Tagsüber ist das alles oben aus der Musikredaktion. Oder ist es wirklich in der Datenbank drin, die auch auswirft, wann was gespielt wurde?
Naja, dann muss die GEMA reformiert werden.
Die muss abgeschafft werden.
Naja, reformiert werden.
Die kann dann einfach Open Source gemacht werden, ganz einfach.
Und kannst du dir auch ein direktes Modell vorstellen, dass man einfach gar nicht über irgendeinen Topf geht, sondern dass einfach derjenige, der bereit ist, Geld zu geben, direkt dem Künstler dieses Geld auch gibt?
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich muss jetzt ehrlich sein, ob ich dann, na obwohl, ich weiß nicht, dieses Modell würde mir eigentlich schon gefallen. Ich würde dann vielleicht doch ein paar Fanny überweisen.
Doch, ein paar Fanny geführt.
Ich meine, bei Open Source ist es ja auch so, dass die Leute die...
Ja, würde ich absolut unterstützen. Statt mir die CD zu kaufen, würde ich diese Form des selbst motivierten, wertgeschätzten und dementsprechend vergüteten Modells dann vielleicht befürworten.
Ja, und vielleicht würdest du die CD sogar noch zusätzlich kaufen.
Das ist gut möglich. Das ist wie in der Türkei. Also da gibt es sowas wie Urheberrecht nicht. Also gibt es schon, aber...
Was weißt du darüber?
Bitte?
Also es ist dort so ziemlich alles free, sage ich jetzt mal. Also jeder Mensch hat dort unten einfach den Grundgedanken, also keiner denkt da an Urheberrecht. Und wenn einem wirklich etwas gefällt und der der Meinung ist, gut, ich will das mir jetzt kaufen und somit meinetwegen eine Unterstützung dem Künstler zukommen lassen, dann tut er das auch. Aber da gibt es jetzt nicht solche Urheberrechtsdiskussionen wie zum Beispiel in Deutschland. Da gehen die Leute viel freier damit um.
Wo hast du das her? Warst du mal da unten oder?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Ah, also heißt das, dass es auch keine Gesetze gibt oder sich bloß keiner drum kümmert?
Es kümmert sich keiner drum. Es gibt Gesetze, aber es kümmert sich keiner drum, weil die Leute bzw. der Staat usw. haben ganz andere Sorgen, als sich jetzt um einen Copyright zu kümmern. Zum Beispiel in den 80er Jahren, Anfang der 90er, 80er Jahren, wo ich mal drunter war, da gab es an jeder Ecke ein kleines Geschäft, da ist man reingegangen, da war zum Beispiel ein Regal, da waren Labels, da hat man sich so ein Label genommen, ist hintergegangen und hat gesagt, ja ich will alle diese Amiga-Spiele haben. Gut, man hat 10 Mark gezahlt für 10 CDs und hat alle Amiga-Spiele kopiert. Mit dem Label von dem Store zum Beispiel.
Die 10 Mark waren im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur eine Kopierservicegebühr.
Das war eine Kopierservicegebühr, aber das hat wiederum zum Beispiel bei mir dazu geführt, dass ich mir gedacht habe, Mensch, Spectrum Holobyte, geniale Firma, cooler Falken meinetwegen, Flugsimulator, zum Beispiel, kauf ich mir, kauf ich mir die nächste Version.
Hast du auch getan?
Hab ich auch getan, hab ich hier im Regal sogar noch stehen.
Hat wie viel gekostet?
Hat damals 69 oder 79 gekostet. Auf jeden Fall habe ich da echt sparen müssen als Schüler. Aber ich habe es echt gekauft.
Scheint doch tatsächlich zu funktionieren, das Thema.
Also es funktioniert. Also wenn ich die Freiheit habe, den Künstler zu unterstützen, jetzt vom Gedanken her, wenn dieses ganze Urheber, Rechtszeug usw. wechselt, dann gehe ich da viel lockerer. Ich unterstütze den dann auch. Auf jeden Fall. Gut, dann gibt es vielleicht einen Künstler, der mir nicht so gefällt, aber ich ihn vielleicht dann doch höre. Und da weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich da dann auch was überweisen würde. Aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, The Fables, der wird auf jeden Fall unterstützt.
Ich denke auch, dass man dieses Modell auf jeden Fall ausprobieren muss, wo jetzt sozusagen sich ja das Kupchen ohnehin nicht verhindern lässt, tun die Leute, die es kostenlos haben wollen, holen sich es ohnehin kostenlos. Und wenn man jetzt noch ein alternatives Bezahlmodell entwickelt, was eben direkt auf den Künstler hin zugeschnitten ist und nicht irgendwie auf den Vertrieb von CDs, dann würde man da auch schon andere Ergebnisse erzielen.
Aber würdest du als Plattenfirma das dem Künstler zulassen?
Die Plattenfirma wird da gar nicht gefragt. Der Künstler würde es eben einfach veröffentlichen und er würde einer Plattenfirma sozusagen den Vertrag geben, wenn ihr aus meiner Musik CDs macht, dann teilen wir uns die Kohle.
Genau, das heißt, das, was eigentlich obszön sind, sind die Kontrollrechte oder auch die Möglichkeit, exklusive Nutzungsrechte zu vergeben. Weil dann kann sich nämlich einer hinstellen und sagen, ne, das aber nicht.
Aber in dem Fall dürfte natürlich dann die Plattenfirma, müsste sie gar nichts an den Künstler zahlen. Das wäre halt auch ein Effekt der ganzen Sache. Und Künstler können normalerweise eigentlich keine CDs machen, von daher müssen wir jetzt die Künstler eigentlich von den Plattenfirmen beschützen, oder?
Also dieses ganze Jammergeschrei dieser alten Herren und Mächtigen über neue Medien, in Anführungsstrichen, halte ich für unfug, denn historisch hat eigentlich noch nie ein neues Medium ein altes wirklich verdrängt, sondern hat insgesamt zu Wachstum geführt. Die einzige Ausnahme war, der Sturmfilm ist weg. Da kam der Tonfilm und da gab es keinen Sturmfilm mehr. Ansonsten hat jedes neue Medium, manchmal wegen VHS, viele Profite.
Nein, es gab den Sturmfilm nach wie vor. Er hat bloß noch eine Tonspur dazu bekommen.
Aber vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz zu diesem Islam zurück. Hast du da ein bisschen mehr Ahnung noch vom Islam? Weil wir sind so ein bisschen bei der Vorbereitung von der Sendung auch auf was gestoßen. Das ist tatsächlich... Und das Copyright und sowas, irgendwie um geistiges, oder den Wert von geistigen Werken, irgendwie nicht...
Den Geldwert von geistigen Werken. Den Wert schon, aber das wird nicht als Produkt anerkannt.
Den Geldwert.
Es ist im Islam, kann ich sagen, also jetzt die Passagen, die ihr jetzt auf der Internetseite da geschrieben habt, zum Islam mit Freiheit und so weiter, kann ich jetzt laut Koran jetzt nicht nachvollziehen, weil ich...
Oder gehen wir auf www.islam.org oder auf www.shariah.net.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass vom islamischen Grundgedanken her das Ganze so abläuft, dass alles für alle da ist, im Endeffekt. Es geht da auch nämlich um Veredelung. Wenn ich zum Beispiel etwas habe, Projekt X meinetwegen, dass ich daraus zum Beispiel Z machen kann, dass mir keiner kommt und sagt, das meinst du, das gibst du nicht. Ich, alleiniger Herrscher über dieses X, behalte dieses X. Du kannst daraus nichts Besseres machen, auch wenn es sehr gut ist für die Allgemeinheit. Das wird zum Beispiel nicht unterstützt, sondern mehr das Veredeln, also dass alles für alle da ist. Weil ein expliziter Satz dazu wäre zum Beispiel, das, was hier auf der weltlichen Erde ist, zum Beispiel, also ich zitiere jetzt mal, wird niemals mit ins Jenseits genommen. Also wird dem, was hier ist, vom Wert her, der Status zugerechnet, das soll für alle da sein, das soll für alle gut sein, alle sollen sich dran laben. Also dieser Gedanke unterspiegelt sich auch in den Menschen, in islamischen Ländern wieder.
Wobei das ja auch im deutschen Urheberrecht nicht unbedingt so gesagt ist, dass es nicht so sein soll.
Das ist jetzt so eine Juristenfrage.
Die Frage ist ja, wann nur sozusagen eine Weiterentwicklung, also wann eine eigene Weiterentwicklung so weit von ihr weiterentwickelt wurde, dass sie sich deine eigenen Leistungen...
Ja, aber du musst ja erstmal mit der anderen rumspielen können, um etwas weiterentwickeln zu können. Das Spielrecht ist eingeschränkt, wenn du da Eigentumsrechte deklarierst.
Du kannst doch im Buch lesen.
Aber nehmen wir mal an, ich nehme jetzt eine Melodie von irgendeiner Band oder ich nehme einen Text von irgendeinem Künstler. Das will ich ja möglicherweise mir in den Rechner laden und dann will ich damit rumspielen und will weiterentwickeln. Und die ersten meiner Versuche, die werden sich sehr ähnlich anhören, aber irgendwann wird es was eigenes sein. Und diese Freiheit will ich haben. Das hast du doch auch nach unserem Recht.
Natürlich hast du nach unserem Recht.
Aber du hast keine beliebige Spielfreiheit.
Ich meine, du hast auch schon festgestellt offenbar, dass diese Urheberrechtsliteratur sich viel mehr dazu eignet, den Ellbogen vor diesen harten Fritz-Tischen hier zu schützen, als sie zu lesen.
Apropos Fritz. Und zwar Chaosradio Nummer 53. Ich wollte das Nummer so eingeworfen haben. Wir reden gerade über Urheberrecht und unsere Nummer, unter der ihr mit uns reden könntest, die hier.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Poxter. Poxter 70 97 110.
Sagen wir mal lieber geistiges Eigentum. Und Orkun ist immer noch am Telefon.
Weißt du denn, wie im Islam gibt es da dann bestimmte Verfahren, nach denen Künstler sozusagen bezahlt werden oder auch Leute, die Bücher schreiben, die sich jetzt von diesen Lizenzierungspraktiken des westlichen Systems abweichen?
Also, ich kenne nicht alle Methoden. Ich bin kein Islamist, etc. Aber die Methodik, die ich kenne, die da zum Beispiel praktiziert wird, ist zum Beispiel, wenn jemand ein Werk herausbringt. Sei es zum Beispiel Literatur oder Musik, etc. Oder ein Programm. Ein türkischer Programmierer soll es ja auch geben. Naja, egal. Auf jeden Fall, dass zum Beispiel, wenn dieses Werk zum Beispiel gut ist und von der Masse als gut befunden wird, dann ist ja logisch, das spricht sich herum, etc. Und eine bestimmte Wertschätzung des Erschaffers, des Schöpfers dieses Werkes entsteht dann und durch dieses Entstehen ist es dann so, dass entweder zum Beispiel eine Spendenmetodik zum Beispiel eingerichtet wird oder dann einfach die Folgewerke von diesenjenigen dann auch gekauft werden oder gefinanziert werden. Zum Beispiel in der Türkei gibt es keine Kirchensteuer. Da wird alles von privater Hand finanziert.
Das ist ja eigentlich in den meisten Ländern sowieso der Fall.
Zum Beispiel. Es muss da immer eine Wertschätzung sein. Das heißt, wenn jemand für gut befunden wird, dann wird der auch unterstützt. Der hat dann auch seine Abnehmer. Ich will nicht sagen, amerikanisches Modell, aber irgendwie orientalisches bei der Marktwirtschaft.
Gibt es in der Türkei, wird da kein Napster verwendet?
Bitte?
Wird in der Türkei kein Napster verwendet?
Ich schätze mal, die Türken, also wenn ich es nicht anders wüsste, würde ich sagen, die Türken haben Napster erfunden.
Führt denn das eigentlich auch zu solchen Sachen, dass wenn jetzt ein türkischer Musiker Musik veröffentlicht, dass die nicht exklusiv nur von einem veröffentlicht werden darf, sondern dass jeder jetzt irgendwie anfangen kann, diesen Künstler auf CDs zu pressen?
Dieses Vertragsmodell bei Musik läuft in der Türkei schon. Also es gibt jemanden, der bringt es raus, etc. Aber da wird keiner öffentlich an den Prangel gestellt. Du hast kopiert. Du hast aufgeführt. Das wird nicht gemacht. Die Vertreibnis, die kalkulieren ganz einfach gut. Es gibt so und so viele Daus, bzw. ich will jetzt nicht Daus sagen. Es gibt so und so viele Konsumenten auf der Ebene, die ganz brav in ihr Geschäft gehen und so weiter. Die kalkulieren eben auf dieser Ebene. Die gehen nicht gleich davon aus, gut, wir haben so und so viele Millionen Jugendliche und davon werden so und so viele kaufen. Aber mit der Zeit verfällt das ganz einfach da unten. Das verfällt, das wird dann allgemein gut. Das fließt dann einfach in die Allgemeinheit hinein. Da schert sich nach, was weiß ich, paar Jahren keiner mehr drum und meckert, Moment, Hallo, Urheberrechtung hier. Der würde allein in einer Ecke stehen. Da würde sich keiner um den kümmern.
Wir fordern die Islamisierung der westlichen Welt. Nein, nein. Warum macht eine Plattenfirma das? Sie möchte daran Geld verdienen.
Die will Kohle kassieren.
Und wenn eine andere Plattenfirma das rausbringen würde? Ja, dann gibt es eben in der Türkei. Auch deine Meinung ist gefragt. Du musst jetzt nicht nur die Türkei sein und was du darüber weißt.
Wie wird sowas denn geklärt?
Vor Gericht? Das Modell bevorzugen, dass ganz einfach die zweite Plattenfirma zu dem Künstler gehen muss und mit dem sprechen muss. Und dass eben keine Exklusiv-Verträge abgeschlossen werden. So nach dem Motto, gut, du findest das gut, du machst einen Hit raus, liebe Plattenfirma, geh, mach. Dann kommt die nächste, hey du, wir wollen für auch unseren Kuchen abhaben, dann sollen die den Künstler fragen. Und diese Exklusiv-Vertragsschiene ist...
Das würde aber schon so etwas wie ein Urheberrecht, sozusagen das Recht des Urhebers an seinem Werk voraussetzen.
Ja, aber erst wenn der Künstler dann auch diese Wertschätzung auf dem Markt hat, das ist ein Dilemma. Jetzt bin ich total aus dem...
Ja, ja, ich meine, wir denken da auch immer wieder im Kreis, weil es halt immer ziemlich schwierig ist, gegen den Status quo anzudenken.
Das wäre eine sinnvolle Modifikation, wenn wir sagen, okay, es ist halt für Musiker zum Beispiel oder für... Na, für Filme ist es schon wieder ein bisschen schwieriger, aber bei Musikern, die dürfen einfach per Gesetz keine exklusiv, also keine ausschließlich Nutzungsrechte teilen, sondern die müssen halt immer noch...
Ja gut, aber vor allem wird ja erstmal festgestellt, dass er in der Lage ist, Nutzungsrechte zu teilen und sonst niemand. Das ist ja dann auch ähnlich.
Das ist so ein Dilemma. Also es kommt immer auf den Künstler drauf an. Es gibt da natürlich diejenigen, die vielleicht mal Kunst gemacht haben und dann nur noch die Dollar-Scheine sehen und die Kasse klingeln hören, die dann wirklich nur noch auf dieser Schiene laufen, aber die halten sich dann zum Beispiel auf dem Markt nicht sehr lange. Da geht es eigentlich um den ehrlichen Künstler. Wenn da jetzt der Künstler ist, der wirklich hinter seiner Kunst bleibt und wirklich auch jetzt von dem ganzen Leben will etc. aber jetzt meintet wegen nicht 15 Ferraris irgendwo in der Garage, in der Jacht, wo er mit Kaschogi zum Beispiel durch die Gegend fährt und dann noch kurz bei Haralds reinschaut. So was, die Künstler, die nicht auf dieser Schiene sozusagen leben, weil das ist hier dann ein Lebensstil. Die Künstler, wo es dann heißt, mein Lebensstil ist meine Kunst.
Das heißt also, die Bevölkerung, die Käufer entscheiden, wie reich ein Künstler werden darf?
So sollte es eigentlich sein. So ist es in der Türkei. Und ich weiß nicht, hier ist das mehr die Industrie entscheidet. Die Geldmagnate und Mammon und all das, das entscheidet, wer erfolgreich wird. Weil sonst würden wir nicht so viel Schund im Radio hören. Ganz einfach, da würde Schund nicht fünf Wochen lang, sechs Wochen lang, Monate lang im Radio sein, sondern da würde Schund...
Gut, aber stell dir vor, die Leute kaufen es doch. Ich meine, die Chancen kennen ja nichts anderes.
oh ja, dann gibt es woanders ein bisschen...
Ja gut, das Problem des Mainstreams werden wir ja sicherlich nicht lösen können.
Aber vielleicht kaufen die Leute den Schund ja auch nur, weil sie manipuliert werden durch die Medien.
Ja gut, ich meine, es geht ja auch...
Ok, ich sag schon mal Tschüss.
War sehr ergiebig. Was ich hier sehr interessant fand, war dieses Modell des gesamten Kulturguts. Und dass etwas, was eben breite Wertschätzung erfährt, eben dann auch allen gehört. Und dann könnte man den Faden auch weiterspinnen, warum sollte eben etwas, was so sehr allen gehört, dann auch nicht allen dazu dienen können, damit Geld zu machen. Das wäre ja eine hervorragende Verwendung für allgemeines Kulturgut. Das ist auch allgemeine Lebensfinanzierung erlaubt. Und eben nicht nur einzelnen lizensierten Gruppen oder Firmen erlaubt, daraus Geld zu machen.
Das Problem ist, warum sollte das nicht so sein, Roland?
Ja du, ich wollte dir eigentlich nur auf was anderes hinweisen. Es läuft jetzt ein Experiment im Netz mit freiem Hergeben von einer Story, Stephen King machen, diesen mehrteiligen Roman, möchte ich nicht sagen, eben eine Story, die kann man sich freie runterladen, unverschlüsselt. Man kann oder sollte aber auch dafür bezahlen.
Genau, 75% aller Downloads möchte er gerne bezahlt. Ich weiß gar nicht, was genau der Betrag ist, den er einfordert.
1 Dollar pro Epilode. Das Ganze soll mal so 10 bis 11 Episoden haben. Er schreibt aber nur weiter, wenn die Rate, also so 15%, durchgehalten wird. Allerdings kann er nur nachvollziehen, was von seiner Seite runtergeht. Da es unverschlüsselt ist und nicht an mich gebunden, kann ich das natürlich auch weitergeben. Das hat er ja nicht mehr im Griff. Nur ich denke mal, solange er seine Kosten dicken kann, dabei ein Gewinn macht, ist das ein ganz nettes Modell. Bisher hat er, glaube ich, 120.000 Dollar eingenommen und auch so viele Kosten bisher gehabt. Ich weiß zwar nicht, wie man da so viele Kosten haben kann. Also er hat das beschrieben in so einer kleinen FAQ für seine Seite. Er hat Anzeigen geschaltet und sowas. Ja, aber so weit sind die Kosten mal, denke ich, fast gedeckt. Aber da schreibt er jetzt noch 10 Teile.
Das ist doch eigentlich das Modell, was man haben möchte, oder nicht?
In gewisser Weise. Nur hier ist eine kleine Sache dabei, die nicht so schön ist. Angenommen bei der dritten Episode sinkt die Kaufrate auf 50 Prozent. Dann hört er auf.
Ja, oder du überweist 10 Dollar. Dann werden wir sehen, wie viel es dir wert ist.
Genau.
Da gab es tatsächlich Anfragen, da haben manche gesagt, Mensch, ich möchte jetzt gerne weiterlesen. Wie kann ich dir mehr überweisen? Also es ist so, geschalten mit Amazon, man kann genau einen Dollar überweisen. Dann sagt er, klick einfach mehrmals drauf. Also es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die sind so ehrlich und sagen, okay, ich möchte gerne unbedingt weiterlesen, ich zahle auch 10 Dollar.
Na vor allem, also ich denke, der Stephen King ist eigentlich nur ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil, erstens schreibt er doch fast immer dasselbe, und zweitens ist er ja nun schon sehr bekannt. Und gerade bei unbekannteren, kleineren Künstlern wird es vielleicht deutlich weniger Leute geben, die das lesen wollen, die aber auf der anderen Seite deutlich mehr bereit sind dafür auszugeben.
Sicherlich, und ich muss mal dazu sagen, ich selber habe die ersten beiden Episoden runtergeladen und habe sie sogar bezahlt, denn ich möchte eigentlich, dass das Ganze ein Erfolg wird.
Ist das spannend?
Ja, eigentlich schon. Obwohl ich sage ehrlich, ich habe noch nie von Stephen King was gelesen. Das ist eigentlich mein erstes Ding, was ich da lese. Ich bin eigentlich nicht so der, der so Horrorgeschichten liest oder so. Also ich bin eher da auch in der technischen Welt zu Hause.
Das ist gerade politisch motiviert sozusagen.
Aber findest du einen Dollar?
Wenn das Erfolg hat und es machen mehrere so, dann kann ich eben auch mal hergehen und mir das umsonst runterladen, weil ich es vielleicht gerade nicht bezahlen kann, warum auch immer.
Findest du nicht einen Dollar pro Kapitel ein bisschen viel?
Finde ich auch. Vor allem, weil das Ding ja 10 Kapitel hat, kommt dann um die 20 Mark das ganze Ding und ich...
Das ist so das Zehnfache von dem, was er normalerweise für ein Buch kriegt.
Genau.
Also für ihn ist es viel, oder?
Ja, richtig viel.
Ein Taschenbuch kostet 17 Mark, also schon...
Und ein Taschenbuch kannst du mit in die Badewanne nehmen.
Ja, gut, also ich hab so ein kleines, ja, Pocket PC und den kann ich ja auch mitnehmen, wenn der Aquafleck oben ist.
Ey, hast du auch eine wasserdichte Tastatur? Das war bisher nämlich immer mein Problem. Die versiffen immer so schnell.
Die sind bis zu ein Meter wasserdicht, so tief ist die Wanne nicht.
Aber, dann kann man da noch mit arbeiten?
Ja, kann man tatsächlich. Ist ja cool. Ich sag mal, das macht nicht jeder unbedingt.
Nein, nicht wirklich nicht.
Eure Thematik ist natürlich hochinteressant. Also ich selber hab da auch ein bisschen damit zu kämpfen, dass ich entwickle Software, aber eben Software nicht für die breite Masse. Sondern eben einzelne Programme für einzelne Firmen. Und das ganz spezifisch. Ich kriege auch nur die Zeit bezahlt. Das heißt also, ich kann das Ding nicht mehrfach verkaufen. Wenn Microsoft was entwickelt, dann können sie es ja millionenfach kaufen. Oder?
Haben dafür auch einen geringfügig höheren Aufwand wahrscheinlich nicht?
Natürlich, aber der kommt ja ums tausendfache höher rein. Wie kann man sich Milliarden Gewinne erklären? Das muss man ja mal überlegen. Also ich finde, es sollte irgendwie Grenzen geben, dass auch Künstler die Musik machen. Die haben ja exorbitant hohe Gewinne.
Roland, stellst du deine Software als...
Das spricht mir hier gerade übrigens Frank, Roland.
Nein.
Was? Oh, Entschuldigung, ich habe dich gar nicht reden sehen.
Hallo, ich bin Tim, ich rede jetzt nicht so.
Entschuldigung.
Entschuldigung, wir sind ja alle so ein bisschen namenlos, wie auch immer. Was mich interessiert ist, ob du auch schon mal daran gedacht hast, deine Software frei ins Netz zu stellen oder tust du das vielleicht schon?
Tue ich eigentlich nicht, weil niemand was mit anfangen könnte im Prinzip, aber es wäre möglich. Also ich vermarkte es der Basis, die bezahlen mir die Zeit und die Firmen bekommen auch die Software und Quellcode. Das heißt, wenn ich mal nicht mehr bin, können die die durchaus erweitern lassen.
Also sie haben auch alle Rechte sozusagen daran?
Nicht direkt. Ich sage zu denen, die dürfen es nicht weiterverkaufen und Urheberrecht bleibt bei mir. Also ich könnte es theoretisch ins Netz stellen. Nur, die geben mir den Auftrag nur deshalb, weil das eben so speziell ist. Die haben irgendwas, das sind meistens kleine Sachen, die haben irgendein Geschäftsmodell, das möchten die gerne abgebildet haben. Die möchten es nicht umgekehrt. Die möchten nicht den Software kaufen und den Betrieb anpassen, sondern eben der andere Weg.
Klar. Und, ja, meinst du, du würdest das vielleicht auch tun wollen? Siehst du da für dich irgendwelche Chancen, die Software ins Netz zu stellen?
Ja, in gewisser Weise schon. Und ich bin eigentlich auch eher so dran. Oftmals denke ich, es ist ein bisschen schade, dass ich das gar nicht machen kann, weil es eben solche Sachen sind, die fast niemand gebrochen kann. Das ist wirklich sehr spätlich.
Du kannst ja trotzdem ins Netz stellen.
Klar, im Prinzip gar nicht. Wäre ich bereit. Es ist eben so, ich muss davon leben. Ich denke auch an Modelle, dass ich eben Software entwickle, die mehr Leute brauchen können, gerade für die PDAs und was es da gibt, die würde ich gerne ins Netz stellen. Also auch im Quellcode. Nur jetzt ist eben das Problem. Da reden wir ja die ganze Zeit drum rum. Wie kriege ich dann dafür das Geld, dass ich wenigstens leben kann?
Ja gut, aber so funktioniert Open Source doch auch. Da entwickeln Leute, und was weiß ich, in welchen Betriebssystemen bedingen, Mailer oder was auch immer, weil sie damit Spaß haben. Aber die Leute werden ja dadurch auch bekannt. Und dann kommen eben viele Firmen, die Spezialanpassungen brauchen für ihren Betrieb und so weiter und so fort. Und da wird exakt das Geld verdient, dass du tatsächlich deine Zeit zur Verfügung stellst. Und an der Stelle, glaube ich, wäre es sozusagen eine gute Idee im Sinne von Werbung für dich, wenn du dein Kram ins Netz stellen würdest. Oder wenn man sich eben tatsächlich an öffentlichen Projekten beteiligt, um eben dadurch klarzumachen, hey, ich kann das und bla bla bla. Ich meine, so läuft es ja auch. Die Amsel ist ja auch deswegen gefragt, weil wir alle wissen, dass sie gut singen kann, weil sie das einfach im Inhof und sonst tut. Ja, so sieht es da aus. Und wenn ich mir die Amsel mal mieten könnte, wenn ich gerade Bock auf Amselgesang hätte, dann würde ich ihr auch Futter dafür geben.
Du sollst das A-Wort nicht sagen.
Wir hätten nicht so viele Amselsfelder trinken sollen.
Amselsfelder? Ey, ich zitiere sowieso gleich.
Man muss eben sagen, das mit dem Futter geben, es muss eben dann auch gewährleistet sein, dass einem jemand Futter gibt. Aber ihr habt da schon recht, wenn man entsprechend durch die Open-Source-Szene bekannt wird, dann kriegt man auch entsprechend Angebote, dort was für Geld zu tun. Oder schaut euch die Red Hat Programmierer an da. Die kriegen ja auch von Red Hat Geld. Und trotzdem ist das Produkt immer noch frei.
Ich habe nochmal eine Frage. Ich weiß ja nicht genau, wie speziell jetzt die Software ist, die du da entwickelst. Also würdest du meinen, dass sie unter Umständen sogar besondere Techniken enthält, die dir jetzt sozusagen durch das Veröffentlichen so entwischen können, dass auch andere Leute sich diese Techniken aneignen und deinen Platz auf dem Markt wegnehmen?
Weniger. Also wirklich, muss ich sagen, weniger. Es sind zwar Sachen dabei, da überlegt man schon mal ein paar Tage, wie man das realisiert. Aber das sind keine, meiner Ansicht nach, keine patentfähigen Dinge oder Dinge, vor denen man nicht Angst hat, dass man sie klaut irgendwie.
Was wäre denn deiner Meinung nach patentfähig?
Das ist die große Frage eben.
Naja, ich meine, was machst du? Du verbindest wahrscheinlich irgendwie verschiedene Subsysteme.
Genau.
Und angenommen, dir fällt da jetzt irgendwie eine super coole Methode ein, wie irgendwie dieser Replikationsabgleich stattfinden kann mit einem integrierten Transaktionsmodell, was vielleicht auch noch fehlertolerant ist. Ist ja durchaus vorstellbar und nicht selten auch mal gefragt. Und jetzt stellst du halt dein Source ins Netz und sagst, aber ja, diese Methode, die gehört mir, die habe ich jetzt irgendwie entwickelt. Und wenn ihr die benutzen wollt, dann müsst ihr mir Lizenzkohle abdrücken.
Wenn es wirklich so etwas Außergewöhnliches wäre, würde ich da sicher drüber nachdenken. Aber dann würde ich auch wiederum denken, Mensch, es gibt so viele Leute, die haben irgendwelche Algorithmen und ganz tolle Sachen frei ins Netz gestellt. Warum soll ich da nicht auch noch meinen Teil beitragen? Also wenn mir wirklich mal der Geistesblitz kommen will. Das ist ja oft mal so, denke ich. Man kann es nicht erzwingen, dass man was Tolles auch findet. Da gehört auch irgendwie die Inspiration des Moments dazu, denke ich mal.
Und findest du es dann in Ordnung, dass andere Firmen das tun?
Leider ja. Also ich finde es nicht in Ordnung. Ich sage leider, ich kann es momentan nicht ändern. Das kann ja eben nur gerade so was.
Ich frage mich nur nach deiner Meinung. Also ich meine, findest du es okay, dass andere Software patentieren?
Nein, finde ich nicht ganz okay. Also gerade bei Software, zum Beispiel, es gibt ja Algorithmen, das habe ich mal gelernt, das ganze Zeug QuickSort. Hat sich doch keiner patentieren lassen, oder sehe ich das falsch?
Meines Wissens nicht.
Ja, jetzt kommt da jemand her, hat einen anderen Algorithmus. Der ist zehnmal schneller, lässt sich den patentieren, jeder muss die Zinskohle abdrücken.
Das wäre nicht schön. Oder er darf ihn nicht benutzen, das sind nämlich die...
Ja, das ist nicht wichtig, genau. Das Ganze wird ja noch viel perverser, wenn wir die Markensache anschauen. Und wenn sich jemand Ballermann schützen lässt, das finde ich so lächerlich. Und dafür Geld kriegt.
Ich glaube, Mercedes zahlt für S-Klasse auch noch irgendwie.
Nicht E-Klasse, das war so ein Franzose, der sich E-Klasse hat schützen lassen.
Ja, sowas finde ich absolut verworflich eigentlich und verworflich. Aber weiter läuft es ja so. Man sieht es ja täglich im Netz an den Diskussionen, was da abgeht, oder die Sache mit dem Explorer, also lächerlich.
Klar, Markt- und Patentrechten in Deutschland ist absolutes Island, also da brauchen wir nicht drüber zu reden.
Geht aber eigentlich alles auf die gleiche Idee zurück, nämlich dass Leute behaupten, das wäre ihre Idee gewesen, obwohl sie die bestenfalls G-Funden, aber niemals R-Funden haben.
Man muss jetzt einfangen, wir haben jetzt die einmalige Chance, durch das Netz und sowas die Dinge frei weiterzugeben. Das kann einem keiner verbieten, auch wenn man es noch so schützt. Sobald man ja was anschauen kann, dann kann man es auch kopieren.
Verbieten kann man es, man kann es nicht verhindern.
Richtig, richtig. Und dann wird es eben auch getan. Ich meine, vieles, was verboten ist, wird getan. Und hier ist es eben so, dass niemand einen direkten Schaden entsteht, sag ich mal, erst mal. So lange, bis die Künstler wirklich kein Geld mehr verdienen, dann wäre es schade.
Na gut, so viel Geld verdienen sie ja derzeit nun auch wieder nicht, wenn man sich den gesamten Musikmarkt, den Umsatz anschaut. Das ist vielleicht für England eine erhebliche Zahl, aber sonst eigentlich nicht. Danke für deinen Beitrag. Haben wir denn noch Bewerber?
Ja, haben wir noch jede Menge. Ich habe einen Peter.
Gut, jetzt muss ich nur lauschen, ob mein Radio da mein Telefon spinnt. Alles klar.
Hast du dich selber gehört, oder?
Ja, hier war irgendwas ein bisschen komisch, irgendein Umschalter oder sowas. Ist ja auch egal. Als erstes wollte ich was zu der Freeware von vorhin sagen. Die Freeware heißt Carbware und das ist durchaus ein gewöhnlicher Begriff. Und das zweite habe ich das Gefühl, dass der Begriff von Open Source irgendwie falsch verstanden wird. Irgendwer meinte vorhin, Open Source, da kriegt man ja auch nur Geld für das Weitergeben oder für die Hohlinge oder das Presse-Net-CD.
Man darf Geld für das Weitergeben nehmen.
Ich darf sogar Geld für die Software nehmen. Das ist überhaupt nicht das Problem. Das verbietet die GNU ja gar nicht. Die GNU verbietet nur, dass ich die Sourcecodes nicht mit weitergebe. Die GNU erlaubt mir, dass ich Software entwickle auf Basis von Open Source Code und dass ich den auch weiter verkaufe. Dass ich dadurch eine Applikation entwickle, die ich kommerziell verwerte. Ich muss nur dann die Sourcecodes mitgeben und erwähnen, dass es auf Basis der GNU ist. Sprich, wer auch immer es kauft, kann damit wieder Kohle schaffen oder kann das Ding weiterentwickeln und machen, was er will damit. Mehr steht in der GNU ja gar nicht erstmal drin. Da ist es nur so verboten, dass ich Geld für den Programm nehmen darf.
Das hatte ich gesagt. Was ich damit gemeint habe, war, dass es sich nicht um einen Verkauf im normalen Sinne handelt, der dann irgendwie nur bestimmte Nutzungsrechte weiter veräußert. Ich bin halt immer gezwungen, es vollständig weiterzugeben. Der Verkauf ist sozusagen nichts anderes als die Entlohnung für die Dienstleistung des Weitergebens. Oder Weiterentwickeln. Nicht für den eigentlichen Wert.
Oder Weiterentwickeln des Werkes. Ich kann dem Werk eine Wertsteigerung zukommen lassen, indem ich es weiterentwicke, in eine neue Version bringe.
Dafür wirst du ja nicht bezahlt.
Dafür kann ich mich bezahlen lassen. Ich muss nicht.
Ach so, für Dritte, wenn die das explizit wollen, natürlich.
Ja, ich kann das benutzen und kann es dann dem Markt zur Verfügung stellen.
Okay, da sprechen wir ja auch die gleiche Sprache.
Die Frage ist halt, ob du dazu gezwungen wirst, das so zu machen. Oder ob du das so machen musst.
Nein, ich muss es nicht so machen. Ich muss es ja prinzipiell nicht so machen. Ich muss nichts verkaufen. Wobei ich da dann wieder zu meinem Problem komme. Geistiges Eigentum denke ich ist durchaus schon möglich, solange wie ich es für mich behalte. Wenn ich es weitergebe, ist es nicht mehr mein Eigentum. Wenn ich irgendeine Sache weggebe, ist sie nicht mein Eigentum. Und Geist kann ich nicht verleihen. Also muss ich ihn dauerhaft weggeben oder teilen, also replizieren. Auch dann habe ich nicht mehr das Eigentum an allem. Das ist das erste, was ich schon mal denke. Das heißt, lange wie ich die Idee für mich behalte, ist sie auch schützenswert. Ich schütze sie, indem ich sie nicht weitergebe.
Moment, Ideen sind aber auch nicht schutzfähig. Also das ist ja auch klar darüber.
Ich schütze sie für mich selber. Ich kann sie nicht vor Dritten schützen. Wenn ich sie einem Dritten mitteile, ist sie nicht mehr geschützt.
Na gut, aber da ist wieder der Unterschied zwischen Ideen und Werken.
Ja, aber Frank, ich kann ja auch ein Werk für mich schaffen und das in meinen Panzerschank oder in meine Wohnung, wo eben sonst keiner reinkommt, oder was auch immer, packen.
Gut, aber du kannst es doch auch auf dem Schreibtisch legen lassen und es irgendwie scheiße finden, wenn jemand bei dir einbricht, das klaut und irgendwie als Buch verkauft. Ja, das habe ich im Werk gemacht.
Das habe ich keine Idee gehabt.
Ein Buch. Ist doch klar, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie in der Badewanne vor mich hin summe und die Ansel klaut, dann meine Melodie irgendwie, ja Herr Rath, dann darf ich es halt nicht zu laut durch die Gegend schreien.
Das ist korrekt. Und da ist es dann wieder, was ich nicht verstehe, warum alle Leute was gegen Urheberrecht haben. Ich habe auch meine Probleme mit dem Patentrecht und ich habe meine Probleme damit, Software patentieren zu lassen, weil entweder ich patentiere das Werk an sich, also das, was ich geschaffen habe.
Was brauchst du denn, dich zu patentieren lassen?
Ich schütze es in dem Fall durch Urheberrecht oder ich schütze da gar nichts. Aber ich kann nicht eine Idee schützen, weil entweder ich vermarkte die Idee, dann habe ich ein Produkt dazu, das ist ein Werk, was geschützt ist, oder ich kann mit der Idee nichts anfangen. Warum will ich sie dann schützen?
Ja, aber das Problem, was durch Urheberrecht, genauso wie durch Patentgesetze entsteht, ist doch die gemeinsame Eigenschaft, dass sich einer hinstellen kann und etwas schützen kann, was eigentlich gar nicht ihm gehört. Na ja, aber Urheberrecht kannst du das nicht.
Na ja, das muss schon dein eigenes Werk sein, das du selbst geschaffen hast.
Ach Quatsch, das ist doch einfach nur die Theorie. Ich meine, wenn jemand die Kohle für Patent- und Urheberrechtsanwälte und den ganzen Kram hat, und ein anderer hat das nicht, und der, der die Kohle für die Anwälte nicht hat, hat irgendwie eine tolle Idee, und der andere ist aber einfach schneller und professioneller organisiert, dann hat derjenige, der im Servicefall diese Chancen, oder diese Schutzmechanismen eben nicht beherrscht, hat einfach keine Chance.
Das ist aber nicht ein Problem des Urheberrechts.
Doch, das ist die Praxis des Urheberrechts. Die Praxis des Urheberrechts ist, dass es Abzocker gibt, die einfach aus dem öffentlichen Raum klauen, und ab dafür. So, und die zahlen sogar denjenigen, die eigentlich kreativ sind, die bekommen dann eine Mark 50 für ihre Zeit, und die anderen bereichen sich dauerhaft an ihren Konzepten und Ideen. So funktioniert es doch. Dazu ist dieses Recht doch geradezu da, so missbrauchbar.
Das ist eben nicht für Konzepte und Ideen da, sondern für konkrete Werke, wie zum Beispiel ein 400-seitiges Buch.
Ja, und? Das ist nicht der Punkt. Ich meine, jetzt redest du von einem 400-seitigen Buch und eben waren wir noch bei Lidern. Lass uns mal bei Lidern bleiben, das ist mir ein bisschen einfacher.
Ja, Lieder sind ein bisschen metaphysischer und weniger greifbar. Das ist richtig.
Vor allem kann man das auch einfacher klauen als 400-seiten Buch.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber auch da bin ich der Meinung, ein Werk ist schützenswert und wenn ich mir eine Melodie zusammenreime, weil dadurch entsteht für mich das Werk, nicht dadurch, dass ich eine Idee habe, sondern dadurch...
Aber wie kannst du denn sichergehen, dass die Melodie nicht schon jemand anders, vielleicht auf der anderen Seite des Planeten mal zusammengesummt hat?
Da kann ich mich sichergehen, aber wenn meine Melodie zu einem Hit wird und seine Melodie nicht, dann ist mein Werk das populärere. Und dann steht mir meiner Meinung nach auch das Recht zu, daraus mehr Vermarktungskapital zu schlagen, als dem, der weniger populär ist.
Also der Teufel scheißt auf den größten Haufen und das ist gut, so sagst du.
Was heißt das ist gut so? Ihr redet immer von öffentlich. Öffentlich ist nur da, wo Masse ist. Und warum soll dann die Masse nicht bestimmen, was...
Mit Masse hat das doch überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Wenn der...
Wenn der was wertfähig ist. Öffentlich ist er nicht, wenn zwei Leute einer Meinung sind. Öffentlich ist, wenn es dann 100 oder 1000 wären. Ansonsten ist es immer noch privat oder begrenzt, abgegrenzt. Und die zwei Leute können sich untereinander einigen. Und die tausend Leute können sich dann auch einig sein, dass sie den Wert begleichen wollen dieses Werkes.
Aber guck doch mal, wenn ich eine Musik mache, einen Lied stelle, und das packe ich ins Internet, in irgendeinen Newsgroup, da kann jetzt zwar theoretisch 5 Millionen Leute darauf zugreifen, aber das sind nun mal gerade keine 5 Millionen Leute, das machen nur drei. Und einer von den drei geht danach aber los, weil der hat eine Werbeagentur, ein Musiklabel, und was nicht alles an der Hand und macht daraus irgendwie, kommt damit auf MTV, weil er den Moderator kennt, und dann sagt er, cool, das ist meins.
Dann hat er es nach mir, dann hat er es von mir.
Ja, aber das muss ich ja alles erstmal beweisen, und dann muss ich irgendwie mir einen Anwalt suchen, und dann bin ich in so einer total bescheuerten Diskussion, wo ich nie hin wollte, weil ich wollte eigentlich, dass das einfach nur im öffentlichen Raum steht. Ich wollte wieder...
Ja, das erkläre ich explizit, dass dieses Werk im öffentlichen Raum steht. Dafür gibt es ja sowas wie die GNU und die GPL.
Ja, aber die gibt es die GNU-GPL auch schon für Musik.
Die gibt es noch nicht für Musik, aber dann wäre es doch eigentlich interessant, nicht zu sagen, wir scheißen auf Urheberrecht, sondern wir machen sowas wie GNU für Musik. Das ist doch dann ein zielentferner Antrag.
Ich meine, es hindert dich doch niemand daran, dein Werk der Musik einfach freizugeben für alle und jedem unbeschränkte Nutzung zu geben.
Doch, es hindert mich die Möglichkeit, dass ein Idiot kommen könnte und es als sein Eigentum deklarieren könnte. Das hindert mich daran.
Richtig, und wenn ich die GPL für Musik schaffe, dann kann mich daran keiner mehr hindern.
Doch, natürlich, weil wenn der andere sagt, da habe ich aber jetzt schon zwei Wochen vorher was draus gemacht und das ist meine Idee, dann kannst du das auch nicht unter GPL stellen.
Wenn er es von mir hat, ja, darum muss ich als erstes formfrei stellen, die GPL für Musik da reinbauen.
Ja, und ich muss es...
Anders machen Software-Programmierer ja auch nicht. Die können ja auch nicht sagen, ich gebe es frei und 14 Tage später fällt ihnen ein, dann mache ich es unter GPL. Und wenn dann jemand kommt, sagen, ach, aber ich wollte doch schon von Anfang an GPL. Geht ja auch nicht, also irgendwo muss ich immer anfangen. Und dann muss ich eben als Urheber dafür sorgen, dass mein Werk unter der entsprechenden Lizenz steht. Und wenn es eine GPL für Musik ist. Da bin ich als Urheber halt in der Pflicht dafür zu sorgen, dass es von vornherein bekannt ist, wie dieses Werk zu verstehen ist. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe auch etwas gegen MP3-Kopiererei en masse, was mich nicht daran hindert, dass ich zum Beispiel bestimmte Sachen erstmal per MP3 haben möchte, weil ich sie einfach auf Arbeit, zu Hause oder sonst wo hören kann, am Rechner. Wenn mir gerade danach ist, dieses eine Stück zu hören, nichtsdestotrotz gehe ich in Lahn und kauf mir die CD. Oder bestell sie mir über Amazon oder sonst irgendwo. Auch wenn sie mich mit ihrer One-Click-Bestellung mal kreuzweise können.
Peter, wir müssen Nachrichten machen. Danke für deinen Anruf.
Bitte, bitte.
So, Nachrichten, da muss ich ganz knapp für. Nämlich 0.32 Uhr.
Fritz Kurzinfo.
Das Wetter erst mal nachts um 10 Grad, tagswechselhaft mit Schauern bei maximal 24 Grad. Die Meldungen mit Gerald Kötterheinrich. Na, immer das falsche Mikrofon. Es tut mir leid, Gerald.
Also mir macht das nichts aus. Dafür höre ich mich jetzt recht räumlich an.
Los geht's.
Werner Wallert und fünf andere freigelassene Geiseln sollen heute in Libyen eintreffen. Dort werden sie mit Staatschef Gaddafi sprechen. Libyen hatte vermittelt und Millionensummen als Lösegeld gezahlt. Wallert wird nach Planungen des Auswärtigen Amtes noch am gleichen Tag in Deutschland zurückerwartet. Die Vorwürfe gegen Brandenburger Polizisten beschäftigen den Innenausschuss des Landtages. Vorsitzender Schulze kündigte an der Wolle so schnell als möglich eine Sondersitzung einberufen. Nach ausländerfeindlichen Angriffen in Teltow und Ratonow hatten die Opfer Polizeibeamten vorgeworfen, nicht ausreichend eingeschritten zu sein. Nach dem Brand im Moskauer Fernsehturm hat Präsident Putin die Misswirtschaft in Russland kritisiert. Das Unglück zeige die riesigen Probleme auch der Wirtschaft auf. Das Feuer forderte vier Tote. Sie wurden in einem abgestürzten Fahrstuhl gefunden. Ab November nächsten Jahres gibt es an deutschen Tankstellen nur noch schwefelarmes Benzin. Der Verband der Mineralölwirtschaft rechnet mit steigenden Benzinpreisen, weil die Herstellung von umweltfreundlicheren Treibstoffen teurer ist.
Fritz präsentiert das bislang schlechteste Fußballteam Berlins. Sie waren in der letzten Saison letzter in der untersten Liga.
Aber jetzt geht's aufwärts mit Empor Hohenschönhausen.
Denn Fritz wird Trikotsponsor von Empor Hohenschönhausen mit freundlicher Unterstützung von Adidas. Los geht's am Mittwoch, dem 30. August, auf dem Dach des Casinos. Torwandschießen über den Dächern Berlin ließen. Denn Empor Hohenschönhausen will hoch hinaus. Aber nicht dorthin gehen, denn es darf keiner weiter rauf, man kann es sich am Radio anhören und das heißt, Fütz.
Chaosradio 53 ist es, 0 uhr 36 haben wir es und ihr hört Fritz. Geistiges Eigentum ist das Thema heute Abend. Wie denn der Umgang mit geistigem Eigentum am angemessensten wäre vielleicht im Studio vom CCC der Frank, der Wau, der Tim und der Andi und am Mikrofon hier jetzt gerade redend der Holger. Ihr könnt mit uns sprechen, weil dazu ist diese Sendung unter anderem auch da, also nicht nur, dass wir mit euch, sondern ihr auch mit uns sprecht. Geistiges Eigentum und der Umgang damit hier ist unsere Nummer.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Podstar, 70 97 110.
Ja, und die gewählt hat und hoffentlich durchgehalten der Frank.
Hallo. Also ich muss sagen, ich ignoriere das Urheberrecht. Also betreffend jetzt auch Software für Programme für den PC, da ignoriere ich das, weil ich eigentlich einwege, diese teure, also dieses Geld, was da Microsoft verlangt, den noch in den Hals zu schieben. Also wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, ich habe gelesen in der Zeitung, dass Microsoft für dieses Millennium als Update 150 Mark haben will und ich mir sage, das ist eigentlich nur ein Patch für ein Programm, das nicht richtig läuft, dann finde ich das eine Sauerei.
Also du bist sozusagen bekennender Raubkopierer.
Ja, aber nur für den Eigenbedarf. Also nicht, dass ich da jetzt einen Handel draus mache, sondern ich benutze Raubkopien für mich selber.
Mal wissen, was Tanja Nolde dazu sagt.
Naja, ich finde das durchaus nachvollziehbar. Ich habe auch nichts gegen Gesetze, aber sie zu ignorieren ist ja auch okay.
Also ich sage mal so, ich bin also auch jemand, der spielt und da bin ich der Meinung, wenn ein Spiel vernünftig ist und korrekt, zum Beispiel wie Diablo 2 in Kaufmannsrichtet, zu vernünftigen Preisen.
Also du bist, wenn ich das richtig interpretiere, hast halt deine eigene Wertschätzung und siehst nicht unbedingt ein, dass man für den Erwerb des Spiels selber bezahlt, sondern eigentlich eher aufgrund einer daraus entstehenden Wertschätzung.
Na sagen wir mal so, also ich habe so ein System, es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Spiele und dann gibt es ja auch wieder Leute, die das Spielprinzip als plonenden Wetter verarbeiten und da gibt es da viel Mist. Und wenn ein Spiel scheiße ist, dann kauf ich mir das auch nicht. Wenn mir das Spiel von der ganzen Atmosphäre gefällt, dann kauf ich es mir. Den Findigden sollte das schon honoriert werden, wobei ich dann auch gucke, ob man da auch eine gewisse Preisgrenze einhält, weil ich auch nicht einsehe, ob man für ein Spiel über 100 Mark bezahlt oder so.
Okay, aber du kaufst das Spiel, damit dem Programmautor dann einen Betrag zukommt? Ja, nicht, damit die Firma dir die CD verkauft und die praktische Serviceleistung der CD produzieren, sondern du willst, dass dem Programmautor irgendwie dazu einen Betrag zukommt?
Naja, schließlich hat er ja da auch ein bisschen Zeit investiert, sag ich mal.
Genau, und wenn jetzt eine andere Firma würde jetzt die gleiche Spiele CD auf den Markt bringen und sie wäre natürlich 70 Mark billiger, weil die zahlt dem Autor keinen Fennigwahl angenommen, es gibt irgendwie kein Urheberrecht mehr, würdest du dann die teurere kaufen?
Naja, sagen wir mal so, also ich würde wahrscheinlich die billigere kaufen, aber ich bin der Meinung, obwohl du weißt, dass der Urheber davon gehext ist. Moment, ich bin der Meinung, man müsste da so ein Modus finden, dass derjenige, der sich das Ding ausgedacht hat, also der Urheber, dass der da schon einen Markt abkriegen sollte. Also da müsste das irgendwie, ich bin auch kein Freund von der GEMA, aber da müsste das irgendwie so eine Firma geben, die so dafür sorgt, also jetzt nicht die Firmen fett und reich werden, sondern die Leute, die sich das halt ausgedacht haben, die Programmierer oder wie auch immer.
Ja eben, aber die Frage ist, brauchen wir dazu ein Gesetz? Also im Moment ist es ja so, dass du, entschuldigung, sind wir mal hier gerade ja unter uns sozusagen, also so ganz Legales sind ja nicht, ne? Und wenn man das jetzt alles nach dem Buchstaben des Gesetzes beurteilen würde, würde man sagen, das ist illegal und aus einem ist das sogar Selbstjustiz. Was machst du? Ich finde das völlig okay, ich mache das so etwas ähnlich.
Ja, bloß, ich habe jetzt mal eine Frage an euch. Ich habe nämlich in einer Zeitung gelesen, dass die Gamer auf PCs eine Gebühr verlangen will. Nun ist meine Logik, dann ist ja eigentlich das Raubkopieren legal, wenn ich da so gesunde Briefe habe.
Das ist tatsächlich richtig, weil du darfst dir, wenn du eine CD im Laden kaufst, kannst du dir davon irgendwie zehn CDs machen und die zum Beispiel in deinem Auto haben zum Hören, irgendwie in deinem tragbaren CD-Player, irgendwie in der Küche, im Bad, im Klo, sonst wo. Das ist ja kein Problem, das verbietet dir ja niemand. Genau, und deshalb, weil du auf, zumindest damals auf Kassetten und ich weiß nicht, wie das mit normalen Datenrodingen ist, sagen wir mal Musikrodingen, da hat es eben auch diese Urheberrechtsabgabe, wo dir ein Künstler dann auch wieder ein Betrag zukommt als kleine Entschädigung dafür, dass du dir eben irgendwie zehn Kopien davon machst.
Ja, aber die wollen nur jetzt auf dem richtigen...
Ja genau, deshalb, weil diese ganzen Rohdingen natürlich mehr in MP3 und auch damit auf die Festplatte verlagert werden. Also an sich ist es nur die logische Konsequenz von der technischen Fortentwicklung.
Naja, okay, aber die wollen ja jetzt für jeden verkauften PC ein WSX 70 Mark oder was da irgendwie verlangen.
Ja, genau.
Und egal, ob derjenige jetzt MP3 oder Musik-CDs hört oder nicht, dann bezahlt er ja trotzdem die Gebühr.
Richtig, aber du würdest die Gebühr bezahlen, wenn du sie nicht müsstest? Sondern du weißt natürlich, du wirst damit irgendwie Unmengen von MP3s kopieren, aber du musst diese Gebühr nicht bezahlen. Würdest du sie denn bezahlen? Glaubst du, dass die Mehrheit der Menschen diese Gebühr bezahlen würde?
Na, ich sag mal so, in jedem Menschen steckt ja ein Zehner Schweinehund irgendwo und das denke ich mal, würde keine große Summe zusammenkommen.
Ja, aber das ist für mich gerade nicht der Punkt, weil nehmen wir mal an, es gäbe jetzt kein Gesetz. Das, was du jetzt im Moment machen würdest, wäre nicht illegal, aber du hättest immer noch, glaube ich, auch wenn es das nie gesetzlich gäbe, würdest du doch einsehen, dass jemand, der ein geiles Spiel programmiert, da auch eine Kumpenmark versehen soll, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Das hat doch überhaupt nichts mit Gesetzen zu tun.
Ich möchte ihr danken, weil ich möchte ja irgendwann, dass derjenige noch mal ein geiles Spiel macht.
Genau. Das geht aber nur, wenn dafür der Fluss des Geldes gesichert ist, nämlich über den Spielevertrieb zum Programmierer.
Nein, Moment, das ging ja auch ohne Spielevertrieb. Hallo, das ging ja doch auch ohne Vertrieb. Das ging doch einfach nur...
Also die Preise, das ist ja meistens so, wenn man sich das jetzt mal anguckt, wenn die Leute immer so viel Geld verlangen, dann steigt halt die Rob-Kopie. Die Anzahl der Rob-Kopien, weil viele Leute können sich das halt nicht kaufen, haben nicht genug Geld, weil die spielen ja meistens Schüler, die haben halt nur Taschengeld. So, wenn die jetzt aber, sag ich mal, ein Spiel für 30 Mark oder 40 Mark verkaufen würden, dann würden mehr Leute Spiele kaufen, dann würde auch wieder Geld in die Tasche kommen, denn die Idee, die ist ja nur immer gemacht worden von den Programmierern.
Ohne Zweifel. Weil CD's genau so sind, wenn CD's nur 10 Mark kosten würden, dann würden so viel mehr Leute kaufen.
Ja, genauso sehe ich das auch im übertragenen Sinne jetzt, was Microsoft betrifft, da sitzen jetzt 100 Programmierer in so einem Betriebssystem, arbeiten da vielleicht ein Jahr oder auch noch nicht mal, wenn man sich die Fehler betrachtet in dem Betriebssystem, und der verdient dann Milliarden dran.
Aber es zwingt dich niemand, Windows zu kaufen, also auch nicht zu benutzen.
Ja, aber wenn man sich mal, wenn ihr jetzt gerade, ihr habt ja mit denen richtig Spiele halt viel und da führt ja nun keinen Weg an.
Ja, außerdem ist die Argumentation auch nicht ganz okay, Frank, wenn du es sagst, du bist nicht dazu gezwungen. Ich habe heute versucht, mir vom Server des Deutschen Bundestages das Grundgesetz runterzuladen und es gibt es das da nur im Microsoft-Third-Format.
Okay, nimm mir die Fantastischen Vier, du bist nicht gezwungen in eine Fantastische Vier-CD-Anzeige, du bist nicht gezwungen, du bist noch nicht mehr gezwungen, die mir die zuhören.
Nee, aber ich bin offenbar bald gezwungen, einen Internet-Service-Provider irgendwie zu wählen, der einen aufgrund von der Fantastischen Vier irgendwie Verständnis von Urheberrechten irgendwie Filter installiert hat und dazu bin ich nicht bereit.
Na, bleibt nicht wieder drei Themenkarten aufmachen, also ich meine, du bist ja so bekennender Kopierer, ich meine.
Ja, naja, also ich bin der Meinung, ich komme jetzt immer wieder auf Bill Gates, der würde auch noch eine Mark verdienen, wenn er so etwas wie Red Hat oder wie das heißt, aufmachen würde und sein Betriebssystem und all das drum und dran als Distribution für 100 Mark verkaufen würde. Dann hätte er vielleicht so, ja, wäre das dann so, dass nicht, wie es jetzt 80% aller Leute weltweit, das Betriebssystem, sondern vielleicht 99% würde trotzdem durch die Masse seine Kohle noch machen. Nee, also Musik und, also ich höre ab und zu Musik, aber die koffe ich mir dann, weil das ist, also da habe ich auch nicht so den Schimmer mit MP3, gut, habe ich schon von gehört, habe ich auch mir schon mal angehört, aber das ist nicht so mein Ding, das interessiert mich eigentlich nicht so.
Also das ist mir Wertschätzung für zu kippen, jetzt mal, das ist faszinierend.
Okay, vielen Dank Frank.
So, Mark, bist du noch da?
Ja.
Ey, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Sie sind auf Sendung.
Das ist mir klar, das sind jetzt auf dem Merkmal sofort. Nee, ihr habt euch doch in Tiroch über MP3s aufgeregt, ne? AOL haben sie damals mal vor einiger Zeit, was heißt damals, vor vier Monaten oder etwas länger her verklagt, weil die amerikanischen AOL den Filter eingebaut haben, dass ihre User keine MP3s downloaden können. Es gibt ja auch Sachen, wie, glaube ich, der NSL macht das, die suchen direkt nach MP3s im Netz. Und es gibt User, die umgehen das mit Umnennen, irgendwelchen schwachsinnigen Endungen. MP3s kann man nie ausmachen, auch den eleganten Tausch von diesen seltenen Dateien.
Und wie siehst du ein zukünftiges Modell, also bist du so mit dem Status quo derzeit zufrieden, wie alles so ist, mit der Verteilung von Waren und wer dafür bezahlt?
Ich stimme meinem Vorredner zu. Die Sachen, die gut sind, kaufe ich natürlich, weil ich will, dass dieserjenige, der es produziert hat, sei es Musik, sei es Spiel, sei es Software, mir nochmal so nettes macht, dass ich nicht mehr von den größeren Sachen abhängig bin, die sowieso größtenteils fehlerhaft sind. Aber was ich festgestellt habe, ich habe jetzt bei mir auf dem Rechner Windows, das schöne B-Betriebssystem, wie es so schön nennt, und vorher Linus drauf gehabt. Ich bin mit Linus gar nicht klargekommen. Vielleicht lag er auch nur an meinem Rechner, oder ich bin von dem B-Betriebssystem so verwirrend geworden. Linus ist wahrscheinlich eher sowas für Freaks.
Es geht ja nicht im Kern um Windows. Meine Windows hat sicherlich seinen Wert, sonst würden es nicht so viele Leute kaufen. Es hat sich ja nicht nur ausschließlich durch widrige Geschäftspraktiken durchgesetzt, sondern eben auch, weil es einen gewissen Grundwert hat und andere Systeme, die nicht in gleichem Maße hatten. Bei Musik ist es natürlich ein bisschen ein anderes System. Man hört die ganze Zeit ein anderes Lied. Das baut nicht ohne Weiteres zwingend auf einer Vorversion auf, die man erstmal erworben haben muss. Wie machst du das mit Musik? Also kopierst du, du kaufst nur CDs?
Nee, nee, ich habe jetzt meinen MP3 Standard-FB-Server da. Da hole ich mir halt ein paar Sachen von dem Album runter. Singles kaufe ich grundsätzlich nicht, weil ich nur wirklich nur ein Liter von mag. Es sei denn diese Remixe, wobei ich da auch sehr oft das Problem mit dem geistigen Diebstahl bei Remixen, weil ja der Ansicht der Inhalt ja auch übernommen wird. Also ich lasse halt ein paar Sachen runter, hör mir die an. Wenn mir das gefällt, was du mich so runtergeholt hast, das sind meistens so circa vier, fünf Tracks von der CD an sich. Und dann kaufe ich mir die.
Was hast du gerade gesagt, du findest das ein Remix, ein Selbststahl darstellt von geistigen Eigentümern?
Ja, das würde ich auch mal sagen. Also wirklich die, die aus zwei Songs, oder aus einem Song, den Inhaltlichen zusammen mit ein paar anderen Sachen neu machen, ist eigentlich an sich geistiger Diebstahl.
Warum?
Na ja, die haben zwar die Remix-Sachen selber gemacht, aber der Ursprungstext, Song, Melodie oder weiss ich was, stammte von dem anderen.
Also ein Remix ist ja meistens auch eine autorisierte Produktion. Dann kommt ja dann tatsächlich der Urautor, oder stellvertretend dafür meistens die Plattenfirma, auf diesen anderen Hösler zu und sagt, mach mir mal bitte ein Remix. Aber was hier jetzt im Prinzip auch angesprochen werden sollte, ist die Tatsache, dass ja eigentlich so ziemlich jedes Lied ein Remix von einem anderen Lied ist. Sonst gäbe es ja gar nicht so viele klar erkennbare Genres, wenn die sich nicht alle irgendwie ähnlich wären. Der Techno-Viervierteltakt wirst du da einfach mal durchgängig finden. Da könnte man natürlich sagen, dass irgendwie der erste, der den Viervierteltakt benutzt hat, dass der jetzt sozusagen das geistige Eigentum an Viervierteltakt hat und alle anderen dürften das jetzt nicht machen, weil es sich ausschließlich um Remixe dieses ersten Liedes handelt. Wo fängt dann sozusagen geistiges Eigentum an, deiner Meinung nach?
Na, geistiges Eigentum fängt da an, wo... Jetzt nehmen wir mal... Hm, das nehmen wir da. Beispiel, jetzt nehmen wir mal Eminence My Name is. Da hast du eine klar festgelegte Melodie, die Drums sind da und so weiter. Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die nehmen das Drumset, die Melodie, die ändern sich etwas ab. Und da haben sie halt das Drumset, was bei den Produzenten oder dem MC, der hinter Eminence steht, halt geklaut, geistig.
Ja, woher hat der denn das Drumset her? Das hat er doch aus seinem Sampler. Und wie sind die in den Sampler reingekommen?
Na, vermutlich durch irgendwelche Realtime-Drums, also wichtige Drums oder halt...
Andere Geräte, die andere Leute hergestellt haben. Und meistens sind die Sounds, die Sounds kommen selten genug ura-originär von den Leuten, die sie benutzen. Also die wenigsten haben tatsächlich eine Trommel da, die sie dann samplen. Das machen zwar auch einige, aber die meisten benutzen halt Drum-Computer, wo Drums drin sind. Oder benutzen eben auch Samples aus anderen Liedern, teilweise auch freien Samples. Wo ist denn dann sozusagen der geistige Eigentum daran? Ist es nur, dass ich irgendwie jetzt diesen Sample benutzt habe, dass es mein geistiges Eigentum ist?
Nee, ich würde das Lied nicht auf eines kleinstes, alle Trümchen auseinandernehmen. Ich würde das Lied im gesamten Werk sehen.
Aber wer macht diese Entscheidung, ob es sich sozusagen um eine neue Erfindung handelt oder nicht? Und wie würdest du das tun? Ich meine, es gibt derzeit mehrere Millionen Lieder auf diesem Planeten. Ist gar nicht so einfach, oder?
Vor allem die Frage ist, sollte es einfach nicht mehr geschehen, oder doch? Ich meine, so sehr wir uns vielleicht sogar darüber einigen könnten, dass das irgendwie Diebstahl ist. Warum nicht? Hey, es ist doch super geil, was da teilweise brauchst. Nee, nee, das frage ich jetzt mal an den Hörer hier.
Es gibt ja auch die sogenannten Cover-Version von Phong. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch eine Art geistige Diebstahl.
Die Frage ist, willst du, dass es das in Zukunft nicht gibt? Und nennst du es deswegen Diebstahl oder sagst du, hey Diebstahl ist cool und lass uns alle freundlich voneinander klauen?
Das ist kein Diebstahl, weil es gibt ja gar nichts zu klauen.
Ich würde es ehrlich gesagt Inspiration nennen und nicht Diebstahl. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo eine Idee aufschnappe, dann lasse ich mich von ihr inspirieren.
Vor allem bei Diebstahl hat man immer den Eindruck, es fehlt irgendwie etwas. Es fehlt ja nichts, es hat sich nur vermehrt.
Diebstahl würde ich das jetzt auch nicht mehr nennen, wenn ich eure Argumentation freundlich würde.
Wobei ihr seid bei der Diskussion schon wieder bei Ideen, merkt ihr das?
Man könnte sogar sagen, dass unsere Geburt ein Diebstahl von Genmaterial unserer Eltern ist, die uns daraufhin verklagen könnten, aber tatsächlich hat sich ja nur irgendwas repliziert. Ja, sie wussten schon, was sie getan haben. Vielleicht wussten sie ja nicht, ich weiß nicht genau, ob sie wussten, was sie getan haben, als sie mich oder dich gezeugt haben, aber in Tatsache ist das ja eigentlich auch nichts verloren gegangen. Obwohl etwas sehr ureigenes von ihnen, was tatsächlich nur bei ihnen so vorliegt, benutzt wurde.
Tja, noch mal kurz, einer könnte uns ja im Prinzip auch verklaren.
Könnten Sie. Marc, danke für deinen Anruf, einen haben wir noch. So, und der letzte aus Erlangen.
Ja, hallo.
Hallo.
Wie wirst du uns?
Über Real Audio Stream, aber ich war ein paar Minuten nach, bevor ich angerufen habe.
Schieß los, Marc, du bist der letzte.
Also ich habe zwei kleine Punktchen noch, einmal zum Anrufer eben vor ein paar Minuten. Der meinte, er findet die Preise von Microsoft Software ungerechtfertigt und kopiert sie deshalb. Also ich bin im Prinzip mit der Vorbedingung seiner Meinung, aber die Konsequenz heißt es für mich nicht, kopiere ich, sondern dann benutze ich immer andere Software. Es gibt nämlich genügend. Und es gibt auch viele konvertielle Software, die ihren Preis auch wert ist und die für dir in ein Open Source Modell auch gar nicht geeignet wäre, weil es einfach nicht so halbmäßig verbreiten würde. Und da finde ich es auch okay, das Geld dafür zu zahlen. Aber das nur nebenbei, also der einzige Aspekt, den ich bringen wollte, ist, ich habe sehr viel über Musik gesprochen und sehr viele Hörer haben über Musik gesprochen. Und es ging dabei fast immer um Pop-Songs, die heute so entstehen in der jetzigen Zeit. Und früher, also wenn ich mal in der Musikgeschichte zurückgehe, das war immer so mein Thema früher, da galt es zum Beispiel nicht, da ging es gar nicht darum, ein Werk zu kopieren oder sich nicht von einem anderen zu unterscheiden, sondern es wurde, also die Entwicklung ist ja mal weitergegangen in der Musik bis heute, bis zum heutigen Zeitpunkt. Und ein Komponist hat irgendwo was vorgelegt und etwas geschaffen, was in dieser Art noch nicht da war. Und dann fühlte sich quasi jeder andere herausgefordert, eins drauf zu setzen. Zum Beispiel hatte Schubert immer zeitlebens das große Problem, dass Beethoven im Genre der Sinfonie einfach nicht übertreffen war.
Oder jetzt nicht wirklich was über den Woiberrecht?
Es gab auch Variationen über die Themen anderer Komponisten. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die dann irgendwelche Lizenzgebühren bezahlt haben. Das wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Hast du dich damit beschäftigt? Habe ich das richtig verstanden mit Musikgeschichte?
Es war durchaus an der Tagesordnung, dass Werke von anderen zitiert wurden. Also nicht kopiert, aber dass sie weiterentwickelt wurden. Die Entwicklung ist heute mit der Musik auch nur noch marginal weiter. Das ist alles, wie gesagt, wie es eben schon kam. Vier Viertel, Takte, Techno, das ist alles...
Gerade mal 20 Jahre alt.
Das ist alles unglaublich. Das ist im großen Teil nicht mehr zu unterscheiden.
Schließlich aus dem, was du gesagt hast, dass du der Meinung bist, dass es sowas wie geistiges Eigentum nicht gibt?
Also das, was der eine als ein geistiges Eigentum ansieht, das unterscheidet sich oft nur in sehr geringem Maße von dem, was man als anderes als sein geistiges Eigentum ansieht. Und dieser Unterschied, wenn der zu gering wird, dann hat man irgendwann das Problem, dass es vielleicht so gleich ist, dass man sich darüber streiten kann. Aber im Grunde ist das meiste an Weiterentwicklung, was jetzt im musikalischen Bereich so im Radio zu hören ist und so passiert, sowieso für die Katze. Das ist nicht wirklich eine Weiterentwicklung. Es ist sowieso alles abgekupfert und irgendwas angewandt. Es hat Knöpfe auf Synthesizer gedrückt, was man irgendwie probiert oder gelernt hat oder so. Und da würde ich diese recht angeistigen Eigentum nicht anerkennen.
Das heißt, es ist im Grunde genommen so, dass genauso wie unsere Gehirne alle im kollektiven Unterbewusstsein hängen, die Computer auch nur am Netz hängen und bloß, weil das zu einem Rechner zugänglich ist, ist immer noch im Netz.
Nein, das kollektive Unterbewusstsein ist wütend an der Stelle. Aber es gibt durchaus Musiker, die etwas Neues schaffen. Also etwas, was einfach nicht da war. Es gibt Filme, deren Prinzip, deren Konzeption einfach neu ist. Also Matrix zum Beispiel. Also die Idee für einen Film ist einfach neu.
Nicht wirklich, es gibt zehn Geschichten, die immer wieder in anderen Konstellationen erzählt werden. Und damit mache ich einfach das Schlusswort. Danke für deinen Anruf, Mike. Das war es, Chaosradio 53. Es sind wirklich so zehn Geschichten immer in anderen Konstellationen. Guckt euch mal, irgendwie so 100 Folgen gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten. Und es sind immer dieselben zehn Geschichten.
Hört euch, 53 Folgen Chaosradio.
Herzlichen Dank fürs Dabeigewesensein. Im Studio waren Frank, Vau, Tim, Andy und der Holger. Gute Nacht und wir hören uns wieder am nächsten, ersten, letzten Montag am Siebessenshow.